Wording.
We're good.
Yup.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link that says flashlight and enter
in the code name Rogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toys for men.
Oh Shit it with that said,
it's so nice to you back.
Buckle up bitches,
man flavors the Joe Rogan experience.
[inaudible]
ladies and gentlemen,
we have returned back from the depths from the silence of two weeks.
Two weeks,
two plus weeks.
Yeah,
it's been fucking long time.
Even I wasn't missing it.
It's been a long time.
I was miss doing it.
I was missing it.
And uh,
I appreciate all the emails and everything.
I had to do a movie and it took off all my time.
There was no,
there was no time to do it and I was going to half ass a podcast on the set,
but some people,
but I got sick.
Tommy Segora fucked me up,
man.
Fuck me up to Thompson.
Gora is one of those dudes that's always sick.
He gets sick,
sick like four times a year.
Like,
you know,
that's,
that's a lot,
you know,
three or four times a year or so.
And uh,
we did cobs and he showed up first day sick as shit and I'm like,
you okay?
Like you okay?
He's like,
yeah,
I think I'm going to be okay.
I just,
you know,
just get some rest tonight.
And meanwhile he had the flu.
All right.
He had the flu and he gave it to all of us.
He just,
you know,
didn't know he had the float.
He just thought he was going to gut it out.
And I was okay on Thursday,
but then Friday night I started feeling like shit.
And then Saturday I took,
uh,
you know,
as see me phentermine,
what it was that stuff.
Yes.
Some Meta phenom in and then really long name that's from a different country.
I took that shit and you know,
a dried out my nose up enough so I could perform,
but I was clearly like a little cloudy,
you know,
I was like,
I was feeling it.
Come on.
And then I had to fly all the way to fucking Boston and it's just something
about those tubes filled with other people's air that is like the worst thing
for your immune system.
If you've got like a kink in your immune system and then you get on a plane.
Whoa.
Do you get jacked?
I landed in,
in Boston.
I had the shakes.
I was like sweating in bed and then I wake up freezing.
Like all of it just swamped.
What are you telling me now?
I'm going to be sick.
The don't make out with Tom Segura.
I've been healthy for like a whole week.
Yeah,
but you still let the bugging.
What the fuck dog that I got shit to do this.
Well,
as long as we're not making out or sharing a microphone,
but he gonna fuck a swap spit here,
but it's in the air.
You don't what?
These microbes,
we just shared a joint.
What do you guys tie going fucking son.
I've got to go home and fucking open up on the old vitamin C pacs,
I think like eight of tonight and I got a flat,
I think.
I don't think I'm contagious.
The doctor told me I'm not contagious.
Once your,
once your fever breaks,
she says you're not contained.
My girlfriend got fucked and I felt right though.
I got a little bit of it but my girlfriend is dead.
Yeah,
it skipped over me.
You gotta be careful if you this when you pull all nighters and do stupid shit.
And this is when you realize it.
Like when I got it,
I was playing pool in San Francisco Cause Thursday night,
uh,
we did a show and then I went out and played pool late late til like six,
six 30 in the morning and then drove it and I was exhausted and I just jacked my
immune system.
Yeah.
And then the next day I had it plus the night before plus your ci was down from
the flag flying.
The CI is down.
That's when the fucking flu goes right to the news and boom,
once it grabs you,
you would look at,
grab your bro.
That's a strong flu.
Well you're telling me is by the time you got on the plane,
you are really getting,
the children should had just strong.
That's fucking flu.
What is it going on in the plane?
Is it just the recycled air is just terrible for you?
It's the APP altitude.
Is that terrible for you too?
And my attitude,
I heard CCI,
we've talked about that.
I think there's probably a bit,
I heard that the recycled air and the plane and it's actually really good like
that.
There's a really good air since you moved that for my Ann Coulter.
No,
no,
they did like a dateline thing about it and I think they actually talked to the
people that design the air systems and planes and they said that no,
they're really good.
They're filtered really well.
So what's the problem?
I think it has to be an altitude.
Just just the flu marinated in you,
Bro.
This,
but the fluid,
the flu,
Marin Ellison,
you know,
we've been getting fluids once a year,
especially the case.
We're over 40 years.
I haven't gotten one in a couple of years.
I've been real good about blue gets stronger these days is a strange,
isn't that what they call it?
A flu.
A fucking getting stronger.
Know that are they all come from farm animals?
Yes.
Almost all of them come from domesticated animals.
They come from pigs and chickens and birds and you know,
that's why when they said this is the bird flu and it was like,
Holy Shit,
the bird flu.
Well they're kind of all bird flus or pig flu is a swine flu.
They're there,
they're fucking livestock diseases.
A lot of times,
you know,
we,
we're probably making these fucking things by forcing all these animals to live
in shit.
Right.
You know,
and be on top of each other.
That's probably where these things come from.
I mean,
I don't know.
But when you start telling me that a lot of fluids or livestock diseases and you
know,
what the fuck we do to livestock,
there's gotta be some sort of a connection.
Absolutely.
You know,
the livestock industry should be responsible for all those deaths,
if that can be proven.
But if it's possible to prove that they're the reason why the flu exists,
but then again you need pork chops.
So what the fuck
did you see that the pyramid shit where they took a robot through that?
That did,
yeah.
They saw some writing that had been unseen for at least 4,000 years I think.
Yeah.
What is it?
It was like red and we're going to figure it out.
I can even see by this pictures I was
in Boston and while I was there when I started feeling better,
which the museum and went to the Museum of fine arts and they had all these
Egyptian art and it was all like ancient ancient shit like 2000 BC,
you know all the way up to like Cleopatra's era,
which is like the later errors.
It's fucking fascinating stuff man.
You know when you really get into Egypt,
how weird they are in comparison to us.
Like when you just look at like what they did,
they had is like super advanced culture that was completely different than ours.
Like so completely different that their writings was all image based.
Instead of like having letters,
they had like images that represents symbols and so all the writing is their
conceptual.
Like the way they looked at the world was completely different than the way we
look at it.
The way we look at things with our writing and our language,
our our western
interpretation of morals and values and what's important,
what's not important.
This is just something we sort of settled on and what you see with the ancient
Egyptians as well here was this really advanced culture that was incapable of
these incredible architectural masterpieces that we're puzzled by today.
Like they'll tell you that.
They know how they built the pyramids all we figured it out.
It is a such a staggering accomplishment that these people,
2,500 BC built these immense perfect stone structures.
I mean they're fucking big.
2 million,
300,000 stones the way between two and 80 tons and some of them were cut from a
quarry that was 500 fucking miles away.
I mean these people were bad,
bad mother fuckers.
They were doing some shit that none of us in this room could ever fucking figure
it out.
It was complex mathematics to cause you had to have every stone cut perfectly by
the time you got to the top because any little room for error,
you're shit would be cockeyed.
You're 2 million,
300,000 stones in the Great Pyramid.
Think about how perfect you have to be the entire way and adjust all the way.
And now it's not like those stones are like this smaller one side and huge on
the other and it's all,
they tried to balance it out the end.
No,
no,
no.
The shit is perfect.
And 2,500,000 years ago,
and it used to be,
we look at it now,
it's all fucked up.
And crumply that's cause they,
they rated it,
it was covered in smooth limestone.
They must have been so fucking beautiful.
But when they built Cairo,
they stole all the limestone from the pyramids.
Those little eight monkey people just chipped away at what their great,
great ancestors had created.
You know these people that are living today on her fucking stupid cars and all
the ridiculous way that we look at the world,
these crazy fucking people.
They didn't have electricity.
They didn't have any leadership roles?
No,
not copper tube.
All they can probe when you don't see that monotherapy drink a five hour fucking
energy like us.
Is there anything mobile?
Think about that.
Is there anything that makes you respect a dude less than when he gets into a
Twitter world with his girlfriend online?
That's the worst.
I don't even know.
Why.
Have you seen one recently?
God,
I seen a ton of them.
I seen people arguing with their spouses on Twitter.
Jenna Jameson and Tito Ortiz do it.
They do like public,
like really public important shit.
Get arrested for fucking Twitter.
Let me say they do it,
but that's like a publicity thing.
Maybe because there there's,
I mean maybe,
maybe they're savvy.
Maybe there's celebrity savvy and you know,
they had to keep her name out there.
I mean that there's,
you could,
you could come up with a rational for a famous person doing it.
I guess if you're one of those famous people that want to be on a reality show,
you know I can,
I can understand,
but I know due to our regular dudes who are having like Twitter wars with the
girlfriend online with the girlfriend will say it would be amazing if I had a
man in my life that actually cared about what I think and then you know the guy
will come back on.
It would be amazing.
That'd be smacking.
Getting that Dick suck carrying rocks.
We'll fucking day like savages.
Me Ask you since she invented shine,
cut the lips to remind you that she suck.
Cock think I'll beat these fucking what the fuck does it?
But you know what to tell you on the job roles it might mean that was very
interesting.
Google it.
We're really part of the AAD society.
What is it going to take?
When are people going to talk about us?
Like that was BC,
there was aid d then what's going to happen post nuclear?
Maybe it's posted to not be posted on.
I was thinking about this the other day,
how interesting and not that some day we're going to be what BC is to us post
nuclear makes sense that they would one day he said,
yeah,
I would think that makes sense.
Then one day they would just say,
you know what?
What changed everything?
Right.
You a piano or an eight beat.
Yeah.
I don't know dog.
I'll be back.
Yeah.
What uh,
what do you want to be?
How do you want to be defined?
How fucking crazy is that?
That someday we're going to be part of a di.
He would,
it's going to be something like that.
And you know,
I mean,
no,
same way BC,
I can't even imagine thinking about BC.
Why don't think it'd be silly.
I think of people with sandals were beads,
you know,
smoking fucking trees looked at a d stand for after death.
The Christ dying.
So I don't think so.
I think there's a,
I think it's actually a term for something that it's been sort of accepted along
the way.
Yeah.
I'm fucked up.
Already hinted that Joe Rogan,
Henry Winkler twittered me or did you work with him on the movie?
That was so amazing.
I was like,
whoa.
Henry Winkler and then went to his page.
He's like only following like 50 people.
One was me.
I was like,
what the fuck is going on here?
He's a great guy,
said some about bad flavors and we will all those guys on the set of heard the
podcast
guys who know you guys who often move on.
Henry Henry Winkler is cool as fuck.
Who was loves.
He loves fly fishing.
We were talking about fly fishing.
Someone took him fly fish and I think in the late eighties or early nineties and
he wrote a book called,
I never met an idiot on the river.
All about the cool people that he met fly fishing and he has all these photos
and the books a places he's gone fly fishing.
That's bad ass fishing is fun as fuck man.
When I was living in Boulder,
there was a company that would take you out and I was totally down to go.
I just never had the time before.
We had to move back.
But uh,
this dude,
there was one of those guys that will like make his own flies and shit.
They have like a station where they sell like feathers,
little things and that's like that type of fishing is a completely different
type of fishing.
You know,
it's like there's an art form to it.
It's difficult.
Like the art of casting a fly Rod,
it's very difficult.
It's not like you can't be drunk and fucked up and yelling with your buddies.
You just dunk align in.
So like some of those guys get a little elitist.
Some of those fly Fisher guys,
they want to pretend that there's some,
but there is something that's a little more intimate about it.
Like you make your own little lure,
you make your own little fake bug,
you know,
and they have all these different instructional video tapes on how to make
lures.
You could find them online and dudes are like fashioning and a little feathers
and shit.
And that's something crafty about that.
You cast it out or catch a big
Stephanie Lockhart does.
He's into all that.
He just went fishing the other day at echo park or something like that.
I didn't catch anything,
but it's like,
that's crazy fishing it echo park really
in a way.
What?
Silver Lake or the ocean STD of some sort of hole in a river or whatever the
fuck it's gotta be so therapeutic for those people.
I just don't think I have the patients.
I've done it a thousand times.
It's so awesome when you're catching fish oil,
you're not catching fish.
It can be such a drag.
I've been on fishing trips where it's like two days of nothing.
You know,
you,
you will go with a buddy and then on the,
by the time,
second day rolls around,
I'm like,
you still haven't caught shit.
You know.
But if you go to someplace like where like salmon or fucking running,
you know,
you go to Oregon where the salmon are running like,
Bro,
you're going to catch some fish caught fish,
salmon,
or have you really,
what'd you catch your story?
What'd you catch?
A couple of fucking savages and some white things are,
boy Gerald,
Eddie's a blackbelt,
Gerald's treatment.
He loves.
He lives up in Oregon.
He goes fishing all the time and he was telling Mike Pyle was telling us about
it too.
Mike Pyle,
when we were in Portland,
he offered to take us out on his dad's pub,
but we couldn't stay an extra day.
But that Portland supposed to have something awesome.
I just wish,
you know,
sometimes you watch the deadliest catch.
That's a little much.
That's crazy.
That's a little,
but those poor motherfuckers crab is not worth that much.
It's not that good.
I mean it's okay,
but I guess for them though,
look,
it's,
it's worth a fuck load of money and it's out there.
They go out six weeks,
right?
Yeah.
Eight,
two months.
You come back with 60 grand.
Is that what happens?
It's not some real money and they go on three times a year,
twice a year.
You know,
that's real money.
But God damn dangerous guys fallen that water man.
And that's no joke.
That water,
first of all,
that water is so fucking cold that you only have a couple minutes to live like
you won't live.
If you're in the water for more than a few minutes,
it's just too fucking cold.
You're just not going to make it.
Your body is going to,
you're in Alaska,
motherfucker,
you were in the ocean and in Alaska.
Fucking Seattle.
Listen,
let's be honest.
Let's see as honest as we can.
Nobody in this room could tell me,
look at my face and go,
I jumped in at the San Diego when it was warm.
It's never fucking know before.
Now I swam in Oregon like a fucking Malcolm,
that story,
cause it's triple used to have a room.
But one time I had a jump.
Treble is uh,
uh,
the booking agent.
But one time I jumped into the ocean because the cops were actually looking for
me in Seattle.
Awful fucking owl Chi beach right there.
But he channeled that into the ocean.
That fucking stripper.
We used to beat each other up once a fucking weekend.
The conflict,
you know what I'm saying?
I stab her.
She hit me in the head with a chair.
So one night I went over there on the ecstasy.
I never forget those high end a piece execute with Josh Wool.
This is 1995 I go over there,
I started fucking with the lady next door and knew if I came over to call the
cops.
So I am banging on them.
The cops not going to do and I have kind
of a belly.
I went under the bed,
the cops are looking at us and they look under the bed and the bed's going up
and down from fucking Oh yeah,
come on right there.
And they arrested me with no shirt on.
So I put the fucking handcuffs on.
I'm on the bus waiting to go to fucking Seattle jail.
They take them to Seattle jail.
So like a four block.
The ecstasy that I eat at nine in the morning started hitting me in the fucking
Seattle jail.
Oh my God.
Well,
I was hiding to book another time.
I went over there and I tried to sneak around and they called the cops on me.
I actually jumped into the fucking ocean and I'll tell you what,
that water is high bulk.
That's what they should call that.
Beach Hypothermia.
That's what it's called.
That and I,
she used to see people out there playing soccer in the water,
like you know,
playing with a soccer ball out there.
What does that volleyball,
oh,
they're so crazy.
Not even penguins do that shit.
That Ocean is,
and I've said it before on this show that out.
That is a place called Bremerton,
Washington.
It's where the navy has all their,
we leech before they've even makes it move.
Bremerton.
Washington gets a call.
That's what were some marines come out because it's the deepest part.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
We had this discussion before.
It's where they go all the way down.
You can't,
they go like right.
It goes like right.
Drops right off,
right under jock who stolen shit.
So the Russians,
the Japs,
nobody could trace that shit deep from that.
They're all,
those motherfuckers are living in Bremerton.
Nobody gives you that.
They have submarines are the biggest mind.
Fuck ever.
Imagine if we were right now in some sort of a metal tube that is under the
fucking ocean a mile deep.
How deep to those fall?
My God.
Oh,
and what's the deepest and submarine goes?
We have to type it up cause I don't want to give you a full,
do you think it would be like if we didn't fly as much would think the same
thing about the flying.
Now you're in a metal tube
like way up in the sky.
The wheel,
the fucking bread strip.
We would die because what's that shit goes into your mind like wait a sec.
Who are the little wallet?
There's a leak.
We'll flop at the bard is in San Francisco.
You know how I found out about,
I've talked about this on stage in San Francisco,
but it's a true story.
I was with fear factor.
We were,
we were filming in Oakland and uh,
everyone was going to get together,
the crew and everybody was going to get together and have dinner in San
Francisco.
And I love those guys.
They're there,
they're all fun guys.
I'm super comfortable with them.
So I thought it would be way more fun to do this to get fucking barbecued.
So I eat this fucking cookie in my room and I am on pollute.
Oh Dude.
It's one of those cookies where he started having very mild hallucinations,
like trails,
like there'll be trails when people are moving,
you'll see like little bits of light following behind them and I'm starting to
see things that aren't there necessarily like a,
I'll,
I'll start to see like movement in front of people.
It doesn't exist.
I mean I was fucking gone man.
I was like way too high to be out in public.
I was having like,
I was having some sort of a membrane moment where I'm like on the brink of
passing through to some other dimension.
It's like right next to us,
but we can't normally access pat fucking hot.
Wow.
I mean,
I'm way too.
And then all of a sudden we're in this bar thing and my ears are popping and so
I go,
why are my ears popping?
Why aren't my ears popping?
And whether you got,
he goes,
Huh?
You don't know.
Or 500 feet of the ocean right now
and all I could think of is what a dumb way to die and how scary that would be
if that thing just started moving and it was a leak broke and then the water
comes rushing in.
What a nutty idea to put a fucking tube under the ocean in a place where the
ground is famous for movie half.
Fuck that.
How long has that been open?
A long time.
It's a camp.
It's a come on.
Seven thing.
Come on.
Seven every time they get to the end.
Yes,
and it's like the same thing with Jack Japan man.
So same thing with this nuclear power plant.
Come on.
They said it can.
You can avoid up to an 8.2 I think we're going to be good while sudden they're
nine hits.
Boom.
This bart system,
what does a good for?
Is it good for a five is a good for a seven we're pretty sure it can survive as
seven would if it's a nine what if you're in there and it's one of those five
minute jammies where the whole fucking Dang is going for five minutes.
You are just shit your pants.
How much can this little flexible metal tube underwater,
how long can this last?
How much can it hold?
What did,
what did the insane pressures it's experiencing every foot of the way as it's
anchored down to this moving ground.
Ocean is moving in a tsunami fashion over it as well because wherever the fuck
the epicenter of it that the shelf lifts up in a fucking giant 500 foot wall of
water going 50,000 miles an hour.
It's headed to the coast.
Shit man
fuel.
If they want to get on the Lincoln tunnel.
Yeah,
I get out the fucking,
you know they say here when you get on the train in La,
they built it a certain way so it has barriers.
Even if there is an earthquake,
it bounces off the fucking things.
Let me tell you something.
Every morning I kiss my wife and I say a fucking pray overpass Jack,
or worse under one.
We saw those pictures.
Those pictures from 94 were shit was flattened with a top level fell on the
bottom level.
It's fucking crazy man.
And we live here every morning I get up,
I could go,
this could be the last mother fucker.
This could be,
I think about it every day type thing like like the grocery store last night I
was thinking about it when I was at,
I had a whole thing of grocery store card and like,
all right,
if it happened now at least I have a bunch of.
Meanwhile,
by the way,
were pussies compared to these people that live in like Alabama.
These people in Joplin,
Missouri,
where three quarters of the town just disappeared,
just disappeared.
Man.
They said that the tornado when it touched down was miles wide.
Do you not crazy.
That is miles.
Why Joey?
So it literally is like a giant array,
sir.
On a chalkboard just erasing giant swaths of land.
Feet Times nine common action.
We used to have a ton of tornadoes in Ohio.
That's one thing I don't miss.
But uh,
California.
Have you ever seen that?
Yeah,
we talked about how he got shit.
We got chased once on the way home from an amusement park in a bus.
There was one chasing our bus and we were in high school or middle school or
something.
There was one in California though the other day lately.
Rare Sacramento.
Sacramento
for this.
They had one.
They reported in La,
not in la,
but la area.
Southern California.
It was recent,
like the last five,
six years or something crazy.
We see that I seen on the news they showed up.
Yeah.
And then it snowed two days ago in Sacramento or three days ago in soccer.
I was reading Josh Berkeley's Twitter yet.
If it was yesterday or last night,
maybe might might've been this morning where he said,
I can't believe there's fucking snow on my front yard.
Like the getting snow in Utah Right now.
Still you think the government's fucker would all weather system.
We didn't call these balloons.
Something's gotta be going on in guys.
I don't know if that's what's responsible for all this.
I think it's fun.
I do know that they're definitely fucking with the weather guys don't know this
responsible,
those tornadoes,
a deadly guys.
It's true.
But you know,
we only have a very limited number of years that we can study a very,
very complex system.
The,
the,
the system of the,
the balance of the ecosystem of the earth,
like where it's warm,
where it's stormy,
where,
you know,
where were thing that shit moves and changes,
there's parts of like,
it's one of the,
uh,
the big pieces of evidence that they point to a much,
much older Egyptian society is that Egypt at one point in time where the Nile
River was,
where the,
like the Sphinx is 9,000 years ago,
that was a tropical rain forest,
like 9,000 BC.
And there's like all this water erosion on the Sphinx and the instincts and
closure and some of the scientists use that as a point to evidence that they
need to reconsider the age of the Egyptian culture because this is like a
completely different environments.
This was under initially as opposed to when they found everything,
which was,
it was all desert and they were saying like,
this is like,
wait,
wait way older than you think it is.
Like we don't know.
We don't really know like the real disasters that happened 20 30,000 years ago.
Like they just found it Lantis in Spain,
it was reading about it in Time magazine.
They're almost positive that they've found the actual area where Atlantis was
and it guess what it is in Spain and it was hit by a fucking giant tsunami,
3000 something BC.
And that's a wrap.
The whole thing just changes,
you know?
And that's,
that happens for everywhere on the planet.
So we have such a limited number of years where we're sort of analyzing data as
far as changing of,
of the climate of the earth.
North America,
just 10,000 years ago,
a blink of an eye north America,
half of it was under a mile of ice.
That's just 10,000 years ago,
man.
In terms of the earth,
that ain't shit.
10,000 years ago there was people just like you.
And I indistinguishable.
They could be at a movie theater.
You wouldn't be able to tell,
put them in new people clothes.
They were the same as us and yet North America was under a half a mile of ice,
you know?
So there's sorts of shit that happens
that we don't know about.
We,
we know,
we know we have ice core samples and we know that we've gone through some
cooling periods and warming periods that,
but shit,
man,
you know,
there's,
there's a giant mystery is to hold it this whole cycle of the earth and whether
or not,
you know,
human beings are interrupting it with global warming,
whether it's man made or whether it's just a natural cyclical thing.
We,
there's,
you know,
there's a that you can argue one way or the other and most scientists believe
what we're doing is not good.
But the bottom line is it changes on its own no matter what.
It changed for the dinosaurs.
It changed for everything.
Everything.
That book.
Not only do we evolve with the planet evolves and 300 years we might be on the
fucking ice heat,
probably will be an article be the hot fucking the Rio de Janeiro with the
Saunders.
Yeah,
it's the,
well they said that the,
the,
the North Pole is moving,
the poll is moving,
set some weird rate of like 40 miles a year.
It's going gonna take a long time a year.
But the like there's some sort of a,
I mean it's,
it's a natural system and it constantly moves slowly,
slowly in a certain direction.
But they've had to like recalibrate land,
landing strips and Florida rarely because,
yeah,
because of the fucking,
the moving of,
of of the Poles,
it's,
it's all,
it's shit is constantly changing mat.
Like this Japan thing,
man,
I feel terrible for those people.
I feel it's terrible that these scientists built this thing and didn't really
think it totally through and didn't really know that if you fuck this up,
you leave a sun in the middle of the field,
it's going to burn through the fucking earth and you can never shut it off.
Don't we have that in the United States so they have it all over.
Of course.
It's not just Japan,
it's us.
We do gentlemen,
this is a wanting thing.
United States in the United States.
None.
No.
God's about this.
They're not even seeing this for what this is.
You know what?
We have the most nuclear plants and plants that anybody in the fucking world
right here in the United States and one of these tornadoes,
anything.
We're just getting a warning,
which we're fucking,
we're not even worried about it.
It's again,
the same thing is with with climate change,
we don't have that much data.
We have way more data on climate change that we do and what happens when you
keep a nuclear power plant around?
We know a few.
We know Chernobyl,
we know three mile island and now we know all this shit in Japan,
but we don't even know exactly how long that thing stays active.
We don't know how long it takes to cool off.
We don't know how long exactly.
It's radioactive.
There's always just done.
It's there.
It's there,
but it's thousands of years.
Man.
Everybody agrees on that.
It's thousands of years.
So that area is far hooked up.
When you live in Colorado,
did you hear much about rocky flats was in a paper much?
No,
I didn't.
Rocky flats is the big place in Colorado,
which people have died over cause you know,
the Colorado,
all you need is a fucking movement in boulder.
They would walk up to the road and blocking light themselves on fire.
Rocky flats is,
you know,
it's uh,
everybody talks about golden scores.
The other side of the fucking Matt is rocky flats.
If you want to look at the golden being good for growing the Rado cores.
So everybody's happy,
everybody's happy.
Oh my God,
cool.
You know,
we have jobs.
Well next to it is rocky flats,
which is,
you know,
why'd you put it in this beautiful fucking part of the world?
You know,
what is rocky flats?
Rocky flats a nuclear fucking John,
I think thing.
Is it a power plant?
I'm not sure.
The double check,
so I don't stick my foot in my mouth.
This is the Joe Rogan.
What's it called again?
Rocky when rocky flats just put rocky flats and see what comes.
It's a strip club man trainees and some dirty fucking,
it's a plant.
It's a nuclear weapons production facility.
Wow.
You have no fucking idea.
Crazy shit.
That's page of the prairie.
Close their nuclear weapons they make.
They make the fucking Bhagavad Gita right there and that explains the airport
about that stuff living there.
It's at the craziest expression ever.
Duncan Trussell told us that when Oppenheimer,
when the first nuclear bomb was detonated,
he quoted the ancient Hindu scripture,
the Bhagavad Gita.
He said,
I am.
I am become God destroyer of worlds.
Is that the exact quote?
I should know his exact quote,
but just the fact that he did that man that he quoted this ancient Hindu
scripture when he came up with some machine that cuts through the fabric or the
fucking universe,
it makes everything exploded.
It just disappear around.
The
rocky flats was a very sore spot in a beautiful part of the fucking country,
which is Colorado.
I'll be granted,
there is nothing out there,
Joe.
You pull up your car and there's God's there with fucking guns.
Zucker's I am become death destroyer of worlds.
That's your death here.
Pull this up because it's him saying it.
Just pull up Oppenheimer.
I am become death to destroyer of worlds cause it's crazy listening to this
dude.
Say it.
[inaudible] guys located.
Do you remember what the saying was?
Rocky flats is near Denver.
It,
uh,
it's operated from 1952 to 1992.
It was under the control of the United States Atomic Energy Commission.
Listen,
this is Oppenheimer.
People were silent,
tear the Bhagavad Gita,
but
now I ended up coming the,
by
the way or another.
Holy Shit.
Could you imagine the responsibility that you must feel that were
at least credited as the one man that without whom the nuclear bomb might have
never been created.
It just took eight minutes to say,
listen,
I fucked some shit up Jack.
Yeah,
you do much drama just to get to the fucking bat.
When he said,
come on man,
you don't,
you don't think that's fascinating.
Oh,
that guy's a super duper genius.
Again,
he quotes Hindu scripture.
I am become death.
The destroyer of worlds and knowing that what he's done was change everything.
Change everything to the point where you have some device that you can detonate
that makes everything around.
It disappeared.
It disappeared,
and there's so much bigger now than they were.
There's the fucking months,
like the power that we have,
like those Hiroshima ones,
the Nagasaki went,
those are okay,
but we got like way stronger shit now and they're working on shit that's even
stronger than that.
You know,
they're working on anti matter weapons.
They're working on anti-matter weapons,
which would literally like dissolve matter.
They would literally,
whatever the fuck form it takes as a weapon,
whether it's a bomb or a beam or it would just everything.
It would just destroy everything.
It would be like thousands of times stronger than we could ever imagine any bomb
being today,
and maybe even more than that.
Maybe I'm just coming up with numbers,
but they don't stop.
They don't stop.
They don't stop with,
they don't stop with nuclear bombs.
They don't stop with this,
this,
this possible.
I mean,
if they really can do anti-matter weapons,
they're not gonna stop with that.
Whatever the next thing is,
it's going to be even more fun.
Does it just seems like they should stop?
It should.
It should stop retarded.
I figured out how to kill life as it stands today with a press of a button
button.
Right,
right.
What else is worth?
I could dissolve you with a fucking gun.
Go below you to fuck up.
I'm going to blow you to fuck up.
Why do you think people continue to push in that direction?
Is it just that we have this natural tendency to accelerate everything
king of the hill?
You know,
we want to be bigger than that.
The next person we want to have,
you know?
Yeah.
But even in a position where the United States is right now,
we're not really threatened by anybody.
I mean,
there's some other,
there's some other countries that have nuclear power and there's other countries
that have strong armies,
but without a doubt,
this is the biggest super power the world has ever known by a long shot.
But we continue to come up with newer,
crazier shit.
I mean,
I guess you have to stay where you at.
You have to,
you have to,
you know,
if you're the big bully your,
you've got to always have the biggest stick.
You have always be ready.
Always be ready for those motherfuckers coming up.
Keep them,
keep them down.
Keep our fucking way of life.
And who was memorial day?
That's what our troops,
boys,
God.
But God damn man,
when you,
when you really fucking think about it like where does it end?
You know,
I mean I know they thought about this shit when he was saying that when he was
saying this,
you know,
I am become death to story of worlds.
He was terrified with the fuck had he done with the fuck even when he was
fucking doing can imagine going to pink berry.
What the fuck he was doing.
Of course he did Joey.
But what it's also one of those things with,
with scientists,
man,
they are scientists because they are inherently incredibly curious people
curious and they're fucking genius and they want,
it's amazing your things out.
And if there is a problem presented to them,
it,
you know,
it's like,
like,
can you develop a nuclear bomb?
Can I,
I don't know.
Can I?
Hmm.
I think I think we can.
I said,
well,
yeah.
And you know,
it's the,
the natural inclination whether or not it's used or not is to create it.
And you can always justify it by saying,
well,
we have to create it first because if we don't create it first than the Nazis
will get it.
And then the fuck everybody up.
That's all you need.
And then everybody says,
okay,
let's make it,
and it's right.
It's true.
Look,
the world is way better with America running things and of Nazi Germany had
taken over in 1947 hopefully.
Hopefully it's way better now.
Who knows?
But Shit,
man,
when does it end?
When do we figure this out?
Do you remember when you were a kid in Vietnam ended?
Do you remember it?
How old were you?
Five.
Seven,
maybe six hours due to this country.
So I didn't really,
I was,
wasn't America dog,
right.
How long would it be?
You been in America for years,
so I didn't,
I was just happy to be having to give a fuck who were beaten up.
I was living in San Francisco.
I,
so you've seen it,
you know,
you've seen the other half of it.
You've seen the demonstrations and
I was a little bit since a little kid though,
I didn't understand any of it.
You know,
I saw demonstrations.
It was just,
to me like the gay pride parade.
It was just like,
oh,
there's a bunch of people doing something and I don't know.
Stand.
I don't know.
I was dripping down my mom's leg.
Are you?
I've never understood war anymore.
I've never understood all these lives.
To get your point across.
I have a disagreement.
I never understood this,
and I understand there's going to be disagreements between countries is going to
be radicals.
I don't like all these lives to figure to make your fucking point.
That's what I've never really enjoyed about war.
But on the other hand,
war was cash wore.
His economy.
War is manufacturing.
You know,
that's what America does.
That's what we do.
We get,
you know,
so I hold a fucking mind to be pro.
My con is I don't want to all these people losing their fucking lives.
You want the oil motherfucker,
go get it.
You want the cash that he had?
Go get it.
You want this month and go get it.
That's one thing that we've always had the resources to do and that's where I
don't have patients.
Why all of these fucking 18 year old kids?
I don't know who watched apocalypse now yesterday unplugged on AMC.
You get stoned.
You walked through the house.
You have an hour before you go to a barbecue and you put something on them.
Fucking sitting there and I'm sitting at Mt.
When I was 18 I rob this guy and I used to do fucking coke and these kids would
19 waking up to machine gun fire.
Are you fucking,
what are you going to fucking tell me?
What do you have to tell me that you had a crack problem that you smoked weed
when you oh,
be do these kids woke up the fucking machine gun fire,
they legs getting blown up.
Just seeing these people and pieces.
You know what that does to you.
I would never want to see that.
I would never want my children or anybody involved in my life to see that.
That ain't no coming back.
When you see that type of death at that age,
I think we don't understand like no fucking idea.
I don't like that people suffering for your point,
Brian.
I don't like what you're doing.
I'm about to send the fucking missile that's so strong.
It's going to go in your house and knock on your door bell going your asshole
and you're gonna blow up.
That impress me.
But I don't want 18 million fucking 18 year olds going down for no reason.
It's not just that,
man.
That's the a minor thing in comparison to the casualties.
They suffer in Iraq.
I mean,
there's nothing.
Oh,
what?
We'd never good when anybody dies.
It's terrible when American soldiers die,
but it's also terrible when Iraqi and Afghanistan civilians die too.
And you know,
we don't hear too much.
Talk about that man.
You don't hear him too much.
Talk about that.
1 million people have died in Iraq altogether.
That's a giant number,
man.
That's a,
that's a scary,
crazy mind bending number,
but more no Nazis,
right?
Wheat and way more.
I don't know.
Who knows Nazis like 6 million Jews.
It wasn't any count to Juke per for one person to,
oh,
how dare you,
everybody.
So I think the Nazis chose to be more,
I think the Nazis just like 6 million,
right?
Wasn't it?
Yeah,
we disputed whatever,
whatever it was.
I think it was more but either.
Either way.
It's not no one,
no one saying what's bad or what's worse.
They're both fucking horrible and disgusting.
It's just,
it's,
we don't,
we don't experience it over here.
And because we don't experience it over here,
the only people that truly appreciate what the fuck is happening in the world
are veterans.
They're the only ones who truly appreciate it.
You know?
And I know a lot of them,
man.
I know a lot of them because of the UFC.
I knew a lot of them because of the Jujitsu.
I know a lot of dudes who have been over there.
I went to high school with a bunch of dudes who went to the first Gulf War,
you know,
and talk to them about it.
It's a,
it's a mind bending shit man.
It never the same human being.
My,
my grandfather was a pow and they actually wrote a book about him and everything
like that about his,
a unit because he was at war,
World War Two.
He was a beat was at B 52 bomber or he was a gunner on when the bombers and that
plane fell from the sky and he had to parachute out and he had like this huge
piece of metal in his parachute that he kept on his desk,
you know,
that he kept somehow,
anyways,
he was a prisoner of war and my full family thought he was,
they were,
he was gone,
you know,
and then you finally got released and stuff like that.
And uh,
how long was he in jail for?
Or He,
I think it was six to eight months or something like that.
I forget.
But,
uh,
they like tortured on,
they did everything to them and stuff.
And I remember right before he died was when um,
call of duty one came out or two came out and uh,
I was playing it and he came over and I remember him sitting down there and just
like freak,
like his eyes were just staring at the TV.
Like he couldn't,
well one,
cause it was a video game.
Predator.
I saw a video game before,
but two,
it was just like you could tell it kind of put them back in there.
It was kind of creepy man.
I had to turn it off because it was freaking me out.
Fuck yeah it would,
holy Shit.
Wow.
He was a prisoner of war in Japan.
Is that where it was or wasn't returning to Germany?
You don't get why fly?
I just thought,
you know what I'm saying,
suck my Dick.
You fucking don't get Wifi.
You have a nervous breakdown.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
That's what I'm talking about.
We've,
that's why we allow all this shit to happen in other countries.
We allow it because we
don't,
we don't experience it here so we don't understand it.
And the only people that do experience it are veterans and they were already
over there.
It's too late.
By the time they experience it,
it's too late.
You know,
they can't,
I mean,
whether the change the way that non-experienced understand war.
No,
there's no way.
The only way to understand wars,
you'd have to be in it.
And if you were in it then everybody would be like,
let's stop this.
What the fuck are we doing?
You know,
there's a Jake shields,
a head trainer,
uh,
I forgot his name to rock something truck Aziz.
He's a over in Afghanistan right now.
And he saw it.
He was tweeting about it and he was tweeting about how uh,
there's like there,
no one's talking about these NATO's tracks that are killing all the civilians.
And there was parts of some woman stuck to a tree.
Like he was walking near this,
this site.
And there's parts of a woman's stuck to a tree.
Just some,
yeah,
just some poor,
innocent person in the wrong place.
When the missiles come,
you know,
how do you know it was a woman was just like better on the gym.
And he didn't,
he didn't specify,
but I guess he knew,
you know,
I got me to seeing it.
It's something like that to Joe Rogan.
So she imagined this is,
this is the scene yesterday I'm watching because it's piece,
I watch her,
she was very fucking funny.
It's the part with a dude from the Godfather,
strong cards in the body.
I don't remember that.
Robert Duval is all
cards on the bodies,
you know,
asis,
spades.
And all of a sudden he does just death everywhere.
And all of a sudden they come to him and they go,
Hey,
this guy is here.
He wants to talk to you.
And it's,
uh,
you know,
winnings.
Father Charlie [inaudible],
who was brilliant is awesome.
He comes over and,
excuse me sir,
he comes over with the fucking thing.
Excuse me,
sir,
Major,
whatever that,
that,
that the tie and Robert do vowels.
Got a little thing on him without a shirt.
I would his fucking hat on spoken and he's like,
yeah,
whatever.
And Lawson in the middle of the conversation,
some other guy comes and goes,
hey sir,
that's lance.
Whatever Johnson,
the famous surfer in the middle of conversation,
he just walks away from weddings.
Father walks up and goes,
excuse me.
So both the black kid,
the break black kid that's now in on CSI.
Yeah,
they both goals sir.
And the lesson that the guy goes,
let's Justin is going to last and Laurence Fishburne cause [inaudible] he goes,
[inaudible] Jasmine the surfing.
He goes,
yeah.
He goes and he looks at fucking Charlie Sheen's following Leo.
He goes,
they will you.
That's a classic line.
He didn't give a fuck.
This guy was a major,
this guy was a surfer and he goes,
they would do that is,
I never caught that.
I've seen the movie 18 fucking times.
I never seen that when a crazy movie where he's he fucking one movie ticket like
six years to make.
Listen,
they had on the crazy one,
the one that got redux on AMC would no commercial and came home.
I bumped into flip Schultz and he gave me two fucking candies that put me in
Jupiter,
had it.
I had to come home and make a pot of coffee.
So I'm watching that last scene when he's creeping in there shooting at the
Chinese and he goes,
he's up on a hill,
and he goes,
he goes,
who's your,
uh,
whatever officer.
He goes,
isn't it you the black guy?
I thought it was human,
but that guy's funny.
That guys are stoked when he keeps walking is a guy that he goes,
you got the mortars and the brothers,
real yoked member.
This Joyce,
he takes his time.
He looks at Pomona fucker.
He's got those black eyes from Memphis with the veins and I'm fucked up.
You can hit Jimmy Hendrix in the back and it tastes not his thing,
and he puts a mortar in it and with them looking at him,
he just goes,
and you see a bad and awesome the G,
they're yelling stops and he just looks at him.
He don't say a fucking word.
Okay?
He goes,
the guy in the morning,
she goes,
do you know who the commanding officer?
And the Black Guy goes?
He just walks away.
He don't even give mine and seen an answer.
I don't remember this is this when a it this way.
He's on finding Kurtz.
The way the the,
and this is the last stop before Kurtz cursing.
This is the last stop before he gets up there.
Marlon Brando's too fucking fat.
He supposed to show up.
If you know the story,
he supposed to show up at training camp to 40 he shows up at three 20 it says,
well,
what are Marlon Brando?
Well,
I feel like,
so what are we going to do?
You're supposed to be an ex soldier.
What are you supposed to do?
He was just fucking black.
My fucking stomach cover put black on me and just showing my face.
That's why.
And all this seems all you see is his face.
You don't see his body.
You see him rubbing his fat head and shit,
but they don't show you his body.
Yeah.
That is one of the weirdest,
most singular performance has ever insane.
And the guy nagging him the whole time and his ear,
you're getting tortured.
Who's the guy with the fall?
But the man is a genius,
but his soul is mad.
What's that crazy hippie?
I don't know.
You know,
he wanted to kill me yesterday,
dude.
He wanted to kill me,
but he's powerful.
He,
you know,
he was just kept bad hippie talk.
It's,
it's just an amazing,
at the end they killed a bull at the same time when they kill him,
Marlon Brando and you hear the end with the doors,
they just do it perfect.
And then doing the dance and the Vietnamese,
whatever the fuck they are killing chickens and they kill it.
It just,
it's brilliant.
Fucking brilliant movie.
I forgot all about the fucking phone.
So what Happy Memorial Day is what I'm trying to fucking say to you.
That's one of those movies.
That's one of those movies that every time you watch it,
if you haven't seen it a couple of years to just shake your head and go,
God damn.
They did trick him with acid.
They did give him mass in the movie.
Who?
Marlon Brando.
Martin Sheen.
So think about a day Martin Sheen gave Marlin Brando director gave Martin sheen
acid and he really,
and he did.
So that scene when he's in the bedroom and he's smashing the window with karate
and he was at,
he was on acid.
They just tricked him.
They just said,
because he talks about it and go and then it's off the lazy.
They were gone.
They was the Philippines.
It's very rude.
Didn't shoot that movie in that way on some fucking went to vista.
You know what I'm saying?
They didn't shoot that on location.
They'd cook that Martin whatever launch he was 16 and took him to the
Philippines.
His parents had a fucking dog.
Shit.
Meanwhile,
that that accurately represents the age of some soldiers mean it's not 16 it's
18 but how much difference is 16 to 18 what's the difference?
16 and 18 are in fucking right there,
man.
Just a few months.
You know,
what is it 30 months?
20 it's supposed to be 24 but what is it like the woods to under and once the
over,
you know what's the lowest amount of months?
It can be 1314 months difference.
Boom.
All of a sudden you're in a fucking kid outta here,
man.
You're in the army at 18 eight bullets flying at that,
just the army camp Pendleton doing push ups with your buddies.
Cheese.
I was talking,
they'd take you and they take it to the fucking jungles of over there.
I mean just 18 dog and you've seen death every day.
You can't even imagine that life.
My gone.
Every time you've got tight with somebody's boom,
he gets it and they just don't get shot.
You can,
can you how old you have to be to go to war is at 18 I think so 18 you can sign
up before that though and like wait.
Right.
Or your parents could take it and I go look at my son's fucking retarded.
You don't want,
he don't give a fuck about to track.
Say you don't give a fuck sick or he wore that.
All he wants to do is shoot people.
Isn't it funny though that when you talk about like the 16 to 18 thing,
it's funny that we have like an age when we decide you're ready for shit.
You know,
I mean it's important but like there's an age like in some countries or in some
parts of the,
even this country,
they'll let you marry when you're 16 and like,
cause you can fuck and Mary when you're 16.
Yeah,
it should be against the law that you shouldn't even be allowed to have have
babies before 21.
Well you know that that teacher that got busted up in Seattle,
the Seattle,
Washington area,
he was banging his,
uh,
his student,
he was a,
um,
I think it was like,
uh,
he was like a fifth grade teacher or something like that and he was like Super
Christian.
It was really creepy cause you go to his website,
he's like all like,
Ooh,
this is how we stop bullies.
Meanwhile he's banging some 15 year old and he apparently they got together and
made out a few times when she was 15.
But she says they didn't have a sexual relationship until she was 16,
which is technically illegal in the state of Washington.
But they're going after him anyway because he was a teacher.
And because it's creepy.
It's creepy.
It's creepy as well.
Listen man,
they can go after you for things being creepy.
I mean it,
you don't want to think so,
but look,
there's the,
like they have obscenity laws.
There's still obscenity laws on the books and certain parts of the country where
luckily that Max hardcore guy,
that guy's a porno star,
it made disgusting.
Porns.
And so that guy's in a jail somewhere because of that.
Have you heard about this thing,
Joey?
Go take a leak.
The uh,
Supreme Court decided to change the fourth amendment over marijuana smell the
supreme court.
This is a crazy story.
And Kentucky versus King,
the U s supreme court has ruled that cops who smell marijuana coming from your
home can break down your door and arrest you as long as they knock first and
claim to have heard evidence or heard you destroying evidence,
that's all they have to do.
Wow.
And it isn't only in what state?
Well,
this is the supreme court sets a precedent.
I mean all the marijuana laws or federal,
the real,
I mean there's,
there's state laws but they're not supposed to be real.
Like in the marijuana,
like in,
in the medical marijuana,
California met California says we allow medical marijuana,
it's passed in 1994 and everyone says it's legal and Hunky Dory.
The federal government can still come in and say,
no,
federally marijuana is a schedule one drug and you're all under arrest.
All you people that are helping out cancer patients and AIDS patients,
you're in jail.
And they did that for a long ass time.
Not only did they do that,
but when they got arrested,
this is where it's really fucked up.
They didn't allow them to use the expression medical marijuana,
you can't use it because federally that term doesn't exist.
So they say,
well,
you selling weed,
you go,
well yeah,
but I was selling medical matter that did the,
did the,
so you have to say yes,
I was telling we,
you can't say no.
They're not going to ask you if it's cancer patients,
they're not going to ask you if it's aids patients.
They don't give a fuck.
What they're going to say is they're gonna allow you to only say what they want
you to say that will incriminate you.
They're not gonna allow you to even use the expression medical marijuana so that
that federally shows how they operate.
But now this new new,
the fourth amendment of the constitution is that the right of the people to be
secure in their persons houses,
papers and effects against unreasonable searches and seizures shall not be
violated and no warrants shall issue,
but upon probable cause supported by oath or affirmation and particularly
describing the place to be searched and the persons or things to be seized.
So they have to have a notice.
They have to have,
they have to go to a judge.
If it was,
listen,
judge,
this guy has been selling marijuana.
This guy has guns.
This guy's a bad guy and this is what we know about them.
There's these,
this is the people that have snitched on him.
This is the photographs we have of his fucking grow up.
You know,
we need a warrant.
Okay,
you got a warrant.
And the judge reviews it to make sure that the cops aren't Joey,
what are you doing?
I can't figure it.
It's just keep going with it the other way.
The other way.
There you go.
Lift it up like a Rubik's cube.
Oh my God.
How can you not figure this out?
You're driving me crazy.
Well that doubt there cope bank guy.
So,
so now,
so now you don't have to go through all that whole process.
Probably don't have to go through that.
All the,
all the cop has to do is knock on your door and say,
I think that you're smoking weed in there.
Let me in.
And then if they hear you destroying evidence,
which is,
it could be a toilet flush going,
holy shit.
The cops are here are destroying evidence.
I think whatever noise that they're going to decipher might be you,
but it's up to them to decide.
And then they kicked down
the United States of America when they kicking their door.
This is Kentucky versus kings is a u s supreme court.
This is,
this is a federal case when they kick in your door though and they see that you
have marijuana and you get like the $80 ticket,
I mean are they allowed to bust you for anything else?
They see,
cause you know how like with $80 ticket is only a state thing.
It's not a physical thing.
Right.
But I'm saying if they,
if they bust on your door,
can they only arrest you for weed or you know how like,
you know how they gonna arrest you for anything that you got in your fucking
house once they're in,
if they,
if see if they'd get it.
Let's see.
Let's say if they get a war and they search your house,
like if they had a warrant for good,
they think you're selling cocaine,
right?
And they go to your house and there's five dead bodies,
there's still,
they're going to arrest you for murder.
You know,
this is a,
this is a scary thing because this is allows cops just say they smelled pot,
but these were only talking about pot.
The idea that you are going to break down someone's fucking house because not
even you smelled them growing it.
You smell the smoke,
you smell them using it,
so you smell them doing something that they want to do and you have a law where
you can break down the door if you think that they're destroying that pod that
they wanted to smoke.
You think they're flushing it?
That is so these are the feds and they come with the house.
Exactly.
That's what this is all about.
The feds ain't coming to my house.
Your House or web band.
That's what I,
that's what I was just going to get to.
It's like,
I mean,
just to add to people guys,
it's like a ricoh or Rico fucking fucks everybody up in the ass.
I don't talk to Joe Rogan.
I just see him once a fucking month.
But if you're going to Joe Rogan and you give him cash and he brings it to me,
I'm involved with whatever Joe Rogan's doing.
You understand me?
It's a criminal enterprise.
So now they added this so you can nail you in a different fucking man.
It's not going to apply now.
I mean,
when are they going to bust out my door and get it or you go get a warrant.
I just,
I agree with you.
I agree with you,
but it's still retarded in scaring.
Oh,
I understand the idea.
I agree that it's probably not going to come up in our lives,
but it's going to come up in somebody's life and the only reason why it exists
at all is because is these a bunch of clueless old fucks that are in charge of
running shit
this country?
Well,
this isn't always going to happen.
If they went by sending your door,
they'll find a thousand of their ways to get in the door.
Yeah,
it's true.
You know,
but,
but you know,
they don't need help.
They don't need this now.
They don't need to help buy the fucking federal government nine 11 I was going
to change our life forever.
It wasn't an AED type deal,
but it changed our life and our liberties.
A lot of our liberties chains and it goes back to the 11 I don't know how this
goes back to it,
but this is just one of the steps that they're taking.
Yeah,
but it's the Joey.
You can say that all you want,
but when you're there,
the law is specifically about smelling marijuana.
It's hot.
It's not.
That's not protecting anybody from anything,
man.
This is nonsense.
This is just nonsense.
That by people that bought into propaganda and have shown through the decisions,
if you showed that this is the way you,
you,
you think after you've really experienced and look at all the evidence,
all that tells me is you're grossly incompetent.
Not just grossly incompetent,
but criminally incompetent.
The idea that you're there to serve and protect and you would actively seek to
lock people up in jail for a plant that's never killed.
A single fucking human being on the face of the planet.
No one's ever owed deed from it ever.
It can't.
It can't happen.
It's one of the most innocuous natural substances you could possibly wrap your
fucking head around.
And the fact that these cons have made a law where if they smell you enjoying
this fantastic plant that makes sex better and food tastes better and makes you
more creative and they smell it,
they can kick down your
fucking door and lock you in a cage.
This is some draconian or well,
1984 movie type shit.
This is ridiculous.
I fucking go and hit a weed store with a gun at lunchtime would read,
man read Ben's real driver is he the driver gets the gun a thousand.
They love the story.
They come in front of my house.
Let's go over there.
Let's go over there and watch whatever the fuck they got to do now is knock on
the fucking door,
knock on the door and say,
we smoked weed and flying to go,
whoa.
Red Bands here.
Let's say you had,
let's say Joe Rogan has a warrant.
He comes to my house for dinner.
This is all this.
This is just less paperwork for his cock suckers.
This doesn't even make you go home and get a warrant.
So what you're telling me is that they smell it.
They don't even have to go to the judge and get signed off on a warrant telling
me exactly,
this is all part of something different.
This is all part of the rolling.
Uh,
I can understand that.
If you say you smelled the gun shot and smell gun powder,
you know what the best thing about [inaudible] smell that he showed up at one
hand,
he showed you the other one.
It became a depressant.
The problem that's going on in this country,
none of you fucking Mo,
most of you.
This is a slow mind fuck of communism from all your little fucking computers and
you Twitter and your message,
they just taking your fuck.
This is communism,
communism,
that this is all communism.
They got us,
they got us everything we say they got us now and they're gonna keep getting
worse and worse.
They're knocking on your fucking door for smelling marijuana.
Really?
It's 2011.
It's crazy.
And Japan is dying over there.
You know what I'm saying?
That these countries,
there's going to be another earthquake and a few fucking weeks.
I mean,
you know,
but when we're worried about you will really,
really,
so what communism aren't you talking about?
They take everything on.
Every computer is a fucking camera.
People,
I dunno if you want to call it,
I don't know if you want to call it communism,
but I agree that it's government.
It's government is getting bigger and government wants more and more power and
government wants less and less responsibility and they want to be able to get
away with shit.
Fucking that sample.
It's hard to,
it's hard to run all these people,
you know?
A lot of us are retarded.
A lot of us are idiots.
It's tough to keep us in line,
but I'll tell you what I did here.
I'll tell you what I did hear from somebody who works at the airport.
Then if you show up to La Actual Burbank,
one of those airports and say,
I'm going to Mississippi and I'm taking a week,
they'll let you bring it out there.
Why is this is what I heard now through the town cop,
that guy,
first of all,
I'm,
I'm every fucking day smoker.
You hear this from a car,
from fucking weed stores and shit.
And I'm telling you have to check.
You have to check your license and show him Michelle.
And what they tell you is that when you get there,
you worry about it.
That's your own problem.
But now you need your medicine.
Tell him.
But they're telling me to save your receipts cause you could put them on your
taxes.
Do I do that?
No,
but this is what's crack a lack of you guys.
I'm just fucking talent.
I wouldn't say,
I wouldn't claim that.
No,
no shit.
No more.
Fuck you to manage the last thing you want to put your fucking,
he's receipt for
$20 a fucking bag of one example.
Yeah.
What they're saying that people are claiming on their fucking taxes.
Those people are going to use a Jag.
It's,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit.
What the fuck?
I think I'm going to show up with my fucking receipts.
You all right.
You fucking retard and get the fuck away
in Burbank.
You show what will I do it?
No,
no,
but I know people who will do that and they say,
worry about it on the other side,
we will not contact the other story to danger.
Danger.
My friend.
That's like going to your mother and telling me you fucking your cousin,
but don't tell your dad fly bro.
He takes things across state lines and shapes.
Yeah.
Then becomes a federal issue.
It's like when you,
if you kidnap somebody and just driving to Vegas,
you're fuck,
you know,
Fab at once.
Not Worth it.
Let's pretend.
Let's pretend you don't have a warrant.
That's even harder there.
That's pretty man.
I'm glad to be some other you haven't dealt with.
Let's pretend I'm under suspicion.
Okay?
For a trafficking narcotics and they don't have a warrant for my arrest,
but that listening to my conversations on the phone,
this is how bad this is.
What is the first thing I say to you when they answer the phone?
When you answer the phone,
Hey,
can you talk?
Do you wanna talk?
What's the first thing I say,
Hey Cox.
Haycock if you're,
and if you're in Vegas and now I'm in La in the,
let's say you have a suspicion,
I get arrested for saying that over a fucking line was awesome.
State the state.
Did you know that?
Fuck,
go.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
Before you say anything before you say you're saying,
if I can't curse and an open line,
it's a federal law.
You don't know it.
It knocked on our rescue.
But if you're on suspicion for something,
this is just the way they can fuck to fuck with you to start.
Stop you at an airport.
It,
they have a law for it.
You can't curse over an open line and state,
did you know this?
Okay,
this is,
that is a fucking genius.
But nobody knows.
But these are the stop you liberties.
This is just to stop you for 15 minutes and stop you and see if something could
come up in 24 hours then through a rescue.
So we use this like if you were swearing,
they could use that as a law to bring you in and then they start getting you for
other things.
No,
listen,
you fucking nothing.
What the fuck?
Joe Rogan,
nobody ask me a question.
Okay.
When you were a detective,
let's say you're a fan of this technique.
Let's say you're a felon detective.
Each,
each state has guidelines and Seattle,
Washington.
If I push red man and Redman has no witnesses,
they have 72 hours to charge me with the crime for Redman,
for Bush and red band.
If they don't get 72 those 72 hours or a window for them to get you for other
things,
it's called detainment.
So when those 12th so let's pretend Oj stabbed his wife.
All right,
and then have nothing to do with in la,
but they want to get them for something.
They'll detain them until they find something and then after 24 hours think I'll
let you go.
Whatever that state particularly the law is.
So you don't have to have knowledge of the fact that it's on an open line for it
to,
yeah,
and it's a federal wire tap.
It's a federal wiretap.
The next time I do the podcast,
I'll come up here and bring you letters.
I get bring me some Spotify letters.
Certify that Shit.
Get that Shit signed by a Notary Jersey from New Jersey Federal Prosecutor's
office.
I have a friend who is involved in bookmaking.
Can we get a wax stamp?
What do you mean?
Whenever he calls me know whenever he called seal.
Whenever they tapped you on the phone.
If I have a phone tap,
it's like crying.
You don't know when you just call me because you're my friend.
Right after they arrested me and they take me to trial,
you're going to get a bunch of mail telling you that we were listening to you on
an open line.
Really?
Yeah,
they have.
These are things they have to do.
See in the old days you knew if your line was tapped,
all you had to do was go to your phone box.
The feds in those days,
we're putting a tag on your phone that said property of the United States
government didn't take a genius.
They would have to put tags now that don't have that.
No more of that.
And they can tag you or bugs or they could tag in the box and the tree.
But in the old days,
if you lived in an apartment,
you'll find phone line.
It was getting tagged or there was a box in a tree.
Somewhere we didn't do was kick the bucket.
Forget.
Did you ever have your shit?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Your water.
And I had friends that had their shit dog.
I'm not going to sit here and go,
you hear a click?
Are you wearing a wire right now?
Yeah.
It's up by Dick sucker.
Come over here.
Suck on this phone.
Might get a little dirty.
It's wire sheriff smile.
But this is what it is,
is what do you understand?
My point is,
so Joe Rohde,
what did they a wire tap you for drugs and 85 and ask him.
But I would never,
do you understand me?
You think of are going to be listening to our conversation because now they can
listen to anything.
Right?
And so right now I'm at home,
but for some reason I tap into red bands and whatever.
This conversation and I was in Vegas for the UFC and I go,
bread bag,
cock sucker.
They're not going to get a cop car to come arrest me.
But so that why you say cock sock?
And everybody said that he got arrested and they can't come or whatever.
And then she got a call from the cop look up.
They can't come over to the rest of it because they're not,
they're just saying they're fucking around.
But let's pretend joggers and under suspicion for something and they're trying
to arrest me for some trainer things
that we know.
All we need is 24 hours to get them.
They're wiring me while they're listening to me.
They go,
we're tap that fucking line.
This is how beautiful the law works for you.
Some time,
tap that line.
Where is he talking to Vegas?
Go get,
go get him for opening over talking over a fucking,
uh,
ultimately they have an open line wearing over an open level or federal
boundaries and they'll come fucking knock on my door.
And take me down there for 24 hours.
Then released me to say it was a technicality,
but at least they took me off the street for 24 hours and Austin as I'm getting
up,
I'll say,
by the way,
Mr. Diaz,
we have another sheet of paper for your warrant.
That's what they do.
That and then they bring it right back.
Can Be,
all these rules are going to be to help a different case.
A Rico case strengthens the case when I got in trouble for kidnapping.
If you get arrested for two or more violent crimes at the same time,
so let's see,
you got a shot one and assault to,
they automatically have to charge you with crime of violence.
It's a state law.
So the assault one,
what's an assault to Swat?
Why'd you hit him in the head with a fucking pipe?
I sought to you shut the bottle up his ass.
I'm not sure.
There's different degrees of,
you see this guy in Oklahoma that's getting a,
he's getting first degree murder because he got robbed and he,
this is what he did.
He went outside is a video of it.
He,
um,
they pull out a gun.
They said,
give us your money.
He pulls out his gun and shoots the fucking guys run.
There's two guys in the place.
The first guy he hit with a bullet and he was a guy who didn't have the gun.
So the one guy had a gun,
one guy didn't,
he shoots the guy who doesn't have the gun.
The guy with the gun runs,
he runs outside with his gun looking for the guy trying to shoot him.
The guy's gone.
He comes back inside.
The guy who shot first is on the ground,
he puts his gun down,
grabs another gun,
walks over to the guy and unloads on him.
Don't do and execute some.
That's murder.
The first time.
The second time he didn't have them,
but Texas in Texas,
they have crimes of passion and now might be a different motherfucker.
They might allow you to get away with that.
In Texas,
yeah,
you can pretty much do whatever you want to you.
If somebody on your property in Texas,
you can catch your wife,
don't bone in some dude and kill the bulk of them and get away with it and it's
a crime not to do fashion.
I mean,
I'm not saying it's going to happen,
but the do we seen you could,
you could argue it.
The dude in Texas,
the old dude that had the shotgun in the house and he was on,
he called the police and the police is worse.
Car Rider will fuck you.
You are.
I'm to go shoot these motherfuckers right now.
They're like,
come back sir.
There wasn't that.
You want us then I come back man.
But he was an ex cop.
He was like fucking 80 and they're like,
sir,
Mine Your Business.
And my dad got,
damn my my business.
I'm getting a shotgun,
sir,
sir.
You hear?
Where was it?
Houston.
Boom.
And he comes back.
He Goes,
God damn,
I got me two motherfuckers fuckers stay in the house.
I'm coming right back.
He went out there in Charlotte again.
That's right.
Berglund next dog store.
Fucking classic.
I'm going to go shoot him.
No Sir.
Stay in the house when we were,
we were like working in town that week.
Did it happen?
Then we see where are we in Houston that weekend when it was happening fast.
Now it's coming back to me.
And what happened to that dude?
That dude get arrested for refusing a fucking a hundred years old.
You give that guy of metal and a gallon of milk and you're going to say you give
him a fucking bell in the pass at Disneyland.
That guy's boss.
You know what I'm saying?
When they get to be 80 he was like,
I'm going to say he was like 68 right.
But just to say,
and do you remember like they had footage of them subtle,
something hit him like out there with a gun,
like come back Negro in Chicago running behind,
boom.
And then he went back in the house and called the web.
Yes.
He could dial nine one one they said I got it.
Yeah,
but what I was saying to you is they charge you with something Joe.
So it makes the plea bargain easier.
Right.
I understand.
I understand that they can use it to arrest.
Come bags.
Hey,
we smelled pot.
We came in,
he had white slavery going on.
Just getting high at the same time.
I can understand.
I understand the idea behind making it easier for law enforcement.
I'm hundred percent pro law enforcement.
I know a lot
of cops and I know a lot of good cops and I know a lot of cops that are good
dudes.
And I know most cops get a shitty wrapped.
But most of the time when you're talking to the cops,
it's cause you fucked up.
That's reality.
And we've all fucked up before.
But I've found in my life that if you're respectful and you treat the cops
straightforward and don't give him a fucking hard time and,
and don't challenge their position,
you know,
just accept what's going on.
He's doing a job.
We have fucking rules there.
Society.
And this guy represents those rules.
So you treat her with respect.
Thank you sir.
And I've never had a fucking problem with cops,
but I'm not a criminal.
I'm not a scumbag.
I'm a criminal and I never had problems with cops.
I had a cop one time with handcuffs on gold,
my zipper pocket over here,
and I had 30 fucking volumes in there.
The blue owns the old school.
The v in the middle,
which would kill a fucking horse,
isn't have Viagara.
No.
He looked at them to say to fucking Momo looked at Nfi aggravated to put them
fucking button and just smile.
I had a cop in bold,
really,
who I took my sides to tell this story on stage.
The other,
when you got arrested,
you got to take your shoes off then your socks,
but you have to turn your socks out.
I had this fucking skunk in my sneaker,
you know,
I had a deep,
deep,
deep in the yard.
It was so much in there.
I was walking with a fucking limp and they pulled me over.
I had a speeding ticket.
The Guy fucking arrested me and when they'd take me back,
the guy who went to pull the sock off and look at the week and he looked at it
as Joe.
He looked at his happiest.
She goes,
it's a Tiva season.
He didn't even know he was talking about.
The next day I go to get charged and they tried with everything,
but they're not charging with the way you've got to charge with the wheat.
Well,
he stole my weakness and charging me ticket.
Fuck you.
If you're going to charge it and trials and everything,
you'd take my week.
Just tried to me one day he tried to run everything except the fucking Charlie
wanted the weed.
If he charged you with the weed,
he couldn't keep the weed.
I've been,
I've been the one thing,
I was pretty simple.
I fucked up a lot and I've always had no problems.
Big Man.
Look,
I know there's some dirty cops out there.
I know there's bad cops.
I know that.
Some,
I've read some shit.
I've seen documentaries.
I know there's no bad everything.
I watched the cocaine cowboys where they talk about how the entire fucking year
graduating year,
one year,
it was like 84 or something.
The entire graduating year,
the Miami Police Department,
the,
what was it,
what is the police?
Uh,
academy attire either died or got murdered or got put in prison.
All of them became corrupt.
It was,
it was one of the worst things that ever happened.
It was like one of those things,
what is it when you have to open up,
they open up a program in Miami in 82 to promote more police officers that were
Spanish.
So they took all these cops.
I had juvenile records like a motherfucker.
All these kids erased them and just gave them jobs to give the department a
better thing.
And there was this one case where they had these four cops,
I forget what they called the harbor cops or whatever,
that they were just pulling people over on the road shooting you and taking your
shit,
throwing you into roared all four of them just on the road like pirates,
bro.
Then have your information and one guy,
what did they call them again?
I forget a four car and then one got out and this happened.
The navy three
82 and the one guy got out in 99 and he became a cook at club mumble in coconut
grove.
And they had signs all over cooking the grove,
don't hire him,
don't go to Mambo.
The guy was a killer.
They would kill us.
They were just going to,
they weren't even arrested and they would just go on and you'd have to know him.
Brian Reichel.
How did that guy get out of jail by your hair blowing your brains out,
throwing you over the causeway,
taking your Mercedes with the fucking porch.
I'm going it back.
When they each got popped,
they each had millions plus they each had 300 kilos of cocaine.
Like they were so far gone,
doing blown.
Just shoot with people.
The harbor cobb's the roadway cops,
the,
and there were all these crazy little fucking specs that,
you know,
Cuban kids dog that had juvenile records,
but they had a promote them.
How'd they get out of jail?
I mean half of them got shouted.
Fuck knows.
I mean,
is it,
I mean when you do something like that,
you got to get life right.
If they catch you executing people,
what did,
what the fuck did they,
how was this guy?
How's it possible that he got,
could've got out.
I have no fucking idea,
but I was 20 fucking years.
I'm sorry about that.
So you vibrating over there.
So what does it,
just different laws back then up to the cops or different laws for like,
listen dog,
if I give you the,
always remember one time,
this is why people don't explain this on television or what he's getting 10
years,
he's getting four fucking years.
Okay?
He's getting four fucking years,
especially with overcrowding door,
four years,
overcrowded prisons,
programs,
first time offenders,
you know all this fucking bullshit that you qualify for,
especially if you're not in violence.
So what you sold the grandma fucking blow.
They don't want you in there really in a way.
You know,
they'll make you pay it and get the fuck out of there.
You're going to pay,
it's going to cost you to get out of it.
But this guy,
these guys were like hardcore murder,
hardcore murder,
but they still get out before,
I think the one guy got out.
But you gotta remember this was 84 and we weren't in coconut grove in 2000,
so that's 15 fucking years.
So they gave this guy a 20 year sentence member.
The more the violent crime,
the parole board turns you down.
So if you're getting 20 years,
you do 10.
But the parole board could turn you down eight times is even if you do heinous
shit,
man.
There was a dude who got released a couple of years ago in Houston and this guy,
uh,
years ago,
I forget how many,
uh,
it was a long time ago,
murdered some grandmother and this little girl,
I think the girl was like three or four and he drowned her in the fucking
toilet,
man.
I mean this guy was a killer.
This guy was a hardcore evil motherfucker.
Killed this grandmother in front of the daughter,
the granddaughter and the good dark granddaughters making too much noise.
So he drowned her in the toilet and killed the both of them and went to jail and
then they let them out and then we'll let him out.
He just immediately started killing checks immediately.
By the time they got to his house,
they found a one of those big drums,
those big metal drums with some woman chopped up and stuffed inside of it and
they found evidence of another murder somewhere else in this house.
And then they couldn't find the fuck.
I don't know if they ever saw many fucked up.
But then again,
you're a very intelligent guy and you understand that people make mistakes when
you can drown
a baby.
Sure you're dead.
So you right now what I'm trying to say to you in person,
I'm trying to say to you is things are bad.
I got a family,
I know people and I go out there and I sling some weeds.
I get fucking eight years for swinging fucking weed and they,
and they locked me and put me under the fucking jail.
But this guy that the system failed and they let their mind,
and this is the flaws I see that they got out.
They listen man.
If it's your first time offender and for cocaine,
I think they should give you a stiff penalty upfront so you understand what it's
like behind back there.
And that's the only way you'll learn.
The same way I learned,
because once you go back there and they ain't no fucking joke,
and I'm not talking about what are you going to get a rate and don't drop the
song I'm talking about you miss your peeps,
Bro,
right?
The people who love you and have faith in you,
they're the ones you hurt.
And when you see their faces,
that's when you make a decision.
Either you're going to go back there or you're fucking not.
I feel that everybody should pay for what they've done in society.
It's the only way you're going to learn from it.
I keep giving you probation.
You're going to keep doing the same shit and let's do it all hand.
Nothing these fucking years with a bunch of hard sisters with no fucking Afro
Sheen and their hair,
when they start looking like,
fuck,
I'm a Goomba.
You'll see what fucking happens.
You'll see us.
You have a shoplift again dog and up from the honest truth.
When you start sitting down and talking to people and the way you and I talking
about,
oh,
we fucked this check or we did a show.
When I talk to you and saying that the time I snapped that mother fucking the
neck,
that was my best day of my life.
And you're like,
uh,
this ain't,
that motherfucking has covered to make its baptism.
You understand me?
So I feel that.
Yeah,
but for me to give you like a Michigan,
I'm reading,
they give motherfuckers 12 years for selling cocaine on the street and shit.
12 years old.
He is nine years.
Hey,
four years.
Did you hear about what they're doing in Palm Beach County in Florida?
He here,
they're having kids,
young,
1920 year old cops and they're putting them in high school and they're busting
kids for selling weed.
Have you heard about this?
Yeah,
we talked about Rogen.
we talked about him before we left.
Do you have three children?
What do you want to do you you're mad at that?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I am at tech.
It's high school and they're smoking weed.
That's all you're arrested him for.
Look,
if you're resting is on the cover of a murder for hire plots and you know
they're planning on knocking over banks and shit when they get out of high
school.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm not a rust and for that I understand it's just pot.
It's all they did.
They went in and this chick pretended to be a fucking high school student.
Hey,
you guys want to buy pot?
And they're like,
yeah,
well you got some next thing and now they're in jail.
I mean the whole thing's ridiculous.
That's now our tax dollars.
Went for a woman to pretend that she was in high school so she could find out
who's got the weed.
You know
you have children now,
so you understand that when you've said it,
I've heard it come out of your mouth.
You know that that's west blurb and that Miami,
that areas assessed.
Pull the phone.
Let's be honest.
But the problem with that area's pills.
Well,
if that even makes it worse,
my fucking lip.
The problem is pills and pills are everywhere.
We talked about it on the podcast before,
but if you haven't seen it,
it's available online.
You need to watch episode of Van Guard
called the Oxycontin Express and they go into a vanguard is this net?
It's one of those shows on one of those weird networks or you're not exactly
sure what it is,
like true TV or some shit like that.
But if you can find it on your Dvr,
it's the shit because they go on these like investigative journalistic
adventures and undercover a lot of shit.
And one of the things they did is they uncovered the whole situation down in
Florida.
It's called the Oxycontin Express.
And it shows how they have these pain management centers in Florida.
And Florida doesn't have a database.
So if you got a prescription for Oxycontin,
which you could easily down there say,
oh,
my back's fucked up.
They look at you,
they go,
one of the guys a little overweight,
maybe he's got a back problem.
Here you go,
they write you a prescription,
they're in the office and you go right next door in the same fucking building.
And they've got the Oxycontin and they sell it to you.
It's like they're legal heroin dealers and they have no database.
So if you went to doctor Joey Diaz and got your prescription,
you could get out of the car,
drive right down the street and go to doctor Joe Rogan and doctor Joe Rogan
writes a prescription for you too.
And then you go down the street,
another fucking 20 miles down the road and get another prescription and you can
do it over and over again because they can't compare.
So you can just show up these pain management centers and get 30,
40 fucking pills.
And these people are the called the oxycontin express because people are driving
down from Kentucky and Ohio.
They're driving down this highway to access the,
uh,
the Florida fucking oxycontin.
They're hanging out and fun in this place.
I mean,
it is a trip,
man.
They,
they show the inside of this building.
This is all these people Jones in and walking back and forth like zombies and
they're sitting there smoking cigarettes sitting in front of the place,
waiting for
it's fucking nuts,
man.
The waiting to get in and get their shit.
And they have all these undercover comics in the undercover cameras are in
interviewing all these people.
So where are you coming from?
Me,
I'm coming to him conduct the,
I'm make this trip once a month,
you know,
I'm need most dope so he can't get,
can't get it in Kentucky,
they have the bus and people left and right and said,
I don't know if it's on Netflix.
I know I watched it online and then I found the show on TV.
I didn't even know about the show to somebody that's on Twitter.
It's at boulevard.
Everybody's holding on the documentary,
the documentary's everybody look you mean that you can get oxycontin.
I know a dude who had a problem and he had a problem because he got a
prescription for it when he lived in Texas and then he moved to California.
He got another prescription for it here and decided to just have himself a
little fucking party.
And so when he did that,
he got jacked.
That looks like Kermit the frog.
The body of Christ compels you.
I overdosed the other day,
Jeff.
Yeah,
I heard you can eat that whole thing or you fuck you.
Fuck you.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of that cookie.
So I had mushrooms and solving,
I don't really remember it and it wasn't that big of a trip.
So I've been kind of Joan solving,
which people should know is in town.
So he up there,
it's like wine country,
go.
Which girl have a nice time,
pop a few mushrooms and it did.
It wasn't as good as I wanted,
so I've been kind of Jonesing
to do it again.
So me and my girlfriend were like,
Hey,
let's do you,
are you measuring your dose or you just like looking at it?
Um,
I usually buy like a quarter or an eighth and usually take half of that.
And Eighth of an artist?
Yes.
Okay.
What is a,
what does announced 16 grams?
What does it,
I saw it the beautiful,
what does announce 16 grams?
I don't know.
I don't go by ounces at all.
I always just,
my by quarters and an age,
28 to 28 grams a quarter,
half a quarter,
half a quarter.
So quarter to seven fucking grant and you're reading a Naif.
Okay.
So I ate,
I ate a full quarter if not more this time around.
And so you went over five grams?
Yeah,
he's fucking crazy.
Oh No.
I went over probably a quarter.
Seven grams or more.
So you crossed over to the dark side?
Yeah,
it was the,
what happened is,
is the,
the mushrooms like,
I don't know if I saw it,
you saw a picture.
One of the caps I had was about the size of a,
a baseball,
maybe it was huge and uh,
the stem was about that big,
which was about the size of,
I don't know,
and and thick.
It was like a huge,
chunky fat.
I've never seen mushrooms that I thought they weren't real.
Like I thought they were like,
they picked the wrong kind and it wasn't going to work because there were so
big,
there was no way to really judge it.
So I'm just like fuck.
And a half of it I was,
it was the dumbest thing ever.
I was just,
I was,
I was like,
you know what,
I want to see a lot of crazy shit.
I'm ready to go deep this time.
And so I made team a girl from a,
uh,
with the mushrooms.
We both made money.
We both made our own separate t so we both had about a quarter each and each one
of our teas.
And she only drank half of it because she started feeling it halfway through the
tea,
drinking the tea.
She's,
yeah.
So she didn't eat,
I did it quick and I just ate it and drank the whole thing real quick.
And then we're both laying on the couch and my body starts twitching.
Like immediately I had all these twitches over my body,
like it was twitching.
And uh,
the only thing I'm rumblings of the universe coming.
Yeah.
The only thing I had eight today,
cause that's another thing in solving that we had eight before.
So the only thing I eat today that day was at beet salad.
That's how you're supposed to do it,
right?
You're supposed to fast for 12 hours.
So I had a small beat sound like seriously small beats out.
So I'm laying on the couch and suddenly I looked at my hand and it would turned
into triangles,
pyramids.
Like I couldn't see my fingers,
there were just tons,
a little pyramids.
And then I looked to the ground dual geometric patterns.
And I've always had in the past,
whenever I was swimming,
I knew where I was.
I looked around and I saw the room.
I knew it was my room,
but it just look trippy.
This was like,
no,
I was not seeing anything that looked familiar.
It was like pyramids and gears and,
and,
uh,
a lot of clock tower type things like inside a clock where it has all this,
the gears and stuff.
It's like you seeing the inner workings of the universe.
And so me and my girlfriend both fucked up as hell.
We're like,
you know,
let's go upstairs and lay in your bed and just chill out and look at things that
you get upstairs.
Uh,
I fell to the ground four times while walking up to the stairs.
My feet would not work anymore.
My legs just would not work and you're supposed to be lying down yet.
So I laid down and it started smelling like dog pee where I was laying,
sorry,
I was trying to crawl and so it's trying to crawl.
So I somehow got in bed and I'm looking at what was the ceiling fan.
But to me it was just a spinning vibe,
like,
like black hole,
like fucking of colors.
And I did,
I thought it was dead.
I was like,
I am dead.
And then I just started getting really sick,
like,
like a poisoned sick.
And so then I was like,
Holy Shit,
I gotta Puke.
No,
I'm not going to Puke.
I tried not to make myself puke.
Finally I get up,
ran to the bathroom south,
fell on the ground to Arenda bathroom,
puked my Puke,
turn into what was beets turned into this red,
furry,
a tree that came out and was just shooting lasers and stuff.
And so I started recording myself trying to find my phone and I couldn't even
use my phone.
So like it took me maybe a half hour to find out how to use my phone because the
phone was just a big kaleidoscope of Shit,
you know?
And then suddenly it all stopped and I was like,
what the fuck was that?
I feel normal.
I don't see anything and everything.
And so it just immediately right back into the world.
And it was,
it was,
I swear to God,
I thought I had a poison.
I thought I had died.
I had no idea what's going on.
But girlfriend was laying in bed just seeing all the same shit,
not feeling she was diags.
You only had half of what I had.
She wasn't puking or anything,
but I was,
I couldn't stop puking.
It was just,
I had nothing in me.
I don't even know what I was puking and I thought I fucking,
no,
it's fascinating.
And you talk about the big ones because I've never had big ones.
I've only had like little ones too.
But Dennis and Terence Mckenna,
when they were in the Amazon in like the 1970s this is when they started having
their psychedelic adventures and they would go take the Iowasca and eat the
mushrooms.
They said the mushrooms are like dinner plates,
like in the Amazon.
These motherfuckers grow and they're like,
you know,
if you grow into a real fertile environment like that,
that's one of the reasons why look at the size of that.
Holy Shit.
Brian's holding one up a picture.
Once they do that looks like a spaceship and then yeah,
look inside of it.
Then on it looks like a fucking like,
I don't know,
like a whale or sperm or an idea
ball.
It only makes sense that those big ones would be even stronger.
Like what if they're stronger?
Poor ounce as well.
But then when I was going to say is dance,
Dennis Mckenna went crazy for like two weeks.
He had some sort of a schizophrenia episode from,
from the mushrooms and lost his marbles and it was like gone for two weeks.
They don't know what happened or what.
They don't know exactly what you mean.
He eventually came back,
but he was apparently just gone for like the longest time.
That's some scary shit.
That was scary.
It was four hours of being inside of a Salvia or a DMT trip and not a bathroom,
which I thought where I was at and my girlfriend sent out.
She would walk in and I would be sitting like Buddha,
like legs cross facing the wall like two inches from a wall.
Just staring at it with my eyes open and that I would look at her and my eyes
would be cross side and then like I would turn back towards the wall and says,
she's
like,
I didn't know what she's like,
I thought you were mad.
She's like,
you were just sitting there facing a wall or something.
I have no idea what the fuck that was about,
but you wouldn't.
You had what's called a breakthrough experience.
You have with all those psychedelic freaks.
All really want to see,
you know,
a lot of people will talk about,
they like to do mushrooms,
but they never really have done mushrooms.
You don't really do mushrooms until you see what you saw.
What you did is have the full blown experience.
And that's one of the reasons why people talk about like why do you make such a
big deal?
They'll say to me like,
why do you make such a big deal about mushrooms?
Why do you make big deal about DMT or the psychedelic experience?
Why do you,
why do you make such a big deal out of it?
So infant tile,
well,
I make a big deal about it because to me it is a big deal.
What I've experienced,
especially DMT,
it's like it's impossible.
It is impossible and it's impossibly beautiful and it's impossibly wise.
And after it's over,
I feel like I'm a better person.
I feel like I learned something and I come back better and nicer and improved
and more enlightened.
I mean,
it sounds ridiculous.
I'm,
I'm agreeing with you.
It sounds ridiculous here in my own voice,
but God damn,
that shit is important.
You know what you did,
you know,
you didn't know exactly how much to take and what if there was a sham and what
if there was a center where you could go to and there's some fucking,
you know,
place in Malibu and there's some fucking people that have been doing it forever.
And Joey Diaz greets you at the door,
come on and got soccer.
We've got a room,
Voya,
he's got his robot and he takes you to the place and everybody does it
correctly.
You know what a beautiful world we could live in,
man.
I'll tell you what I,
I started fucking with that shit when I was younger and that was from the east
coast.
There was no fucking mushrooms.
But I had these scientists,
kids that were like 30 when I was like 15 and they,
they were scientists that he's Strausberg and every week they were into all this
psychedelic and Syd Barrett and all this shit.
And it would make stuff.
And I gotta be honest with you,
when I first started fucking around with acid,
to me it was just another way of getting fucked up,
killing the pain.
Because I started doing acid before my mom died and I started triple like I
remember the trip and could well people don't know is you found your mom dad was
dad and I was on the way down.
But what's really fucked up was that that was just amazing.
But you know,
I started doing acid for the same reasons that everybody else.
I didn't even learn about hallucinogenics and the alt button until you use
later.
Like when I did window pane in the eighth grade,
I went to see the stones.
I was mind boggling.
What do you mean by the alt button?
You know,
you made a very,
you made one of the best ever,
uh,
correlations.
He said that doing DMT is like pressing the alt and delete,
control,
alt,
delete,
control,
alt,
delete.
It's like rebooting.
It's like we blew the world.
And I remember being a kid and not just doing it to be high.
And then after my mother died and you know that you use when buying them,
even six months,
I started selling microdot acid and every weekend pick up a different 500 hits
or something.
Dell a four way acid.
I pick up and these guys were great.
That's what they did.
They trip,
they tripped the right way.
They would,
they would take sheets for a weekend and go camping and you know,
I would be petrified of the staying
out in the fucking louvers for three days.
That one,
they listen to led Zeppelin and I mean it was crazy,
but that way eggs in campfire,
they would fucking cook and trip.
That wasn't me.
Like they had no hundred hits.
One time for him.
Took him in four days and the camping trip and they had the pictures and it was
just great.
But it wasn't for me.
I wasn't ready.
But then after my mom died,
I'd go into these a psychosis.
He's like,
I couldn't figure out why an uncle wouldn't talk to me or something.
And that night on the way home,
I knew that my uncle,
me always at war when I was like,
I'm just making an example.
There was just a problem.
Maybe a girl didn't like me or you know what killed my mother always had a
dilemma in my head.
When you're,
when you're 16 you always want to know answers.
And I remember I would take a hit of acid and go home and you know,
fucking come tripping like one had been a junior in high school or sophomore,
but I knew if I trip on myself,
that's when I got the full effect and have to go home and take a fucking,
he had a window pane or fall away acid and I get speakers and I listened to like
black sabbath sabotage or master reality,
which just blows you out of the fucking water.
And I would,
and at the end of the night,
whatever prom,
my hat or whatever inner problem I was thinking about,
that was really in a way,
I mean it'd be gone or solved.
It sued over right?
It was Susie.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
At least now I knew where I stood.
Don't you think that's why I want so many problem kids,
so many troubled kids have this deep,
deep connection to music,
you know?
I mean,
how many kids do you see that are just all fucked up?
And they got long,
crazy greasy hair,
but they got a shirt on if their favorite band,
they're headed to that concert and their fucking life depends on this show being
good.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
you're talking about like some really fucking dark and depressed people,
but they loved their music man.
Very funny.
When we were in Philadelphia,
a kid I hadn't been at the bitter end came up to me.
What's the bitter end had been around?
It was a rock club.
I did a rock club.
You did that in New York.
Right.
And if he came to my neighbor and he brought me a joint and he,
uh,
he brought me to join.
He was very nice.
And then Phil,
he came with his other friend,
he drove from New York City.
They go like Nyu and he came up to me and he said to me,
hey man,
I'm thinking of doing mushrooms,
ash,
which should I do?
And I want him to fucking reach over and smack them.
You know,
in my mind I'm like,
Yo,
that loss that you want to ask me,
what the fuck to do?
Well,
if he's a yard,
hold on.
I was,
one of the story was 19 point okay,
so I fucking talked about it and then I emailed them,
we emailed each other and I really thought about it his age and stuff.
And then I thought about when I was 16 and I had no answers.
I had no answers.
I had no mother,
no father,
no social security check and all that one.
It was answers.
All I wanted was help and I remember that at all.
I would get my help was was listening to black sabbath,
doing a hit of acid,
listened to music.
It always sued me.
I always thought I had a connection,
but I was he asthma when I was walking the 30 years after the blizzard of Oz was
on VH one yesterday.
Tremendous about how he left Sabbath and opens up this bandwidth is Randy Rhoads
and no songs.
But you know what?
They were dumb fucking songs.
Who gives a fuck?
Some of them,
but they made me go through at that period of my life.
So what differences are making when people watch this podcast,
who they listened to this podcast.
You know what,
man?
We feel the same void for some people.
And I'm telling you this,
I didn't know this.
I didn't know how responsible you are when you do this.
When you talk and you say certain things about your feelings and your emotions,
people jump onto you because they feel your pain or their admiration or their
happiness and all the sudden you become a part of them and they become a part of
the human because that's what happened to me.
As stupid as this may sound,
you've known it.
You had martial arts,
your escape when you were a kid.
We all have to have some fuck of escape when you're a kid,
especially when you don't come from the fucking Brady bunch you're doing.
I think that one of the things that helps people with this podcast too,
and I get a lot of emails and Twitter,
it's about it is you know there's a lot of people that don't have anybody cool
to hang out with.
They,
they go and they're stuck.
They're stuck wherever the fuck.
They don't need to know that there's people out there like this.
They need to know that.
They don't have to think the way that everybody else is thinking.
You can think positive man.
You can be cool to people.
You can get the fuck out.
You know?
Don't,
don't blame the world.
Just get out.
I know when I was a matter how you got started with Jersey,
I knew when I was 16 I was leaving Jersey jump rope.
I didn't know that.
I know I had to go.
Absolutely.
I knew it because it wasn't for me.
I didn't want to fuck [inaudible].
I thought there was something in Colorado.
I thought the answer man.
I thought there was something.
I didn't know how to get there.
Don't even talk to me about Colorado.
I still want.
This is what this podcast is.
One of the things that keep me around for real,
this podcast him since we came back,
that's when we started it.
I came back from Colorado in November and Brian and I started this thing in
December.
Boom.
Just like that and needed something to do.
I was,
I was sick.
I was living in the woods on a top of a mountain and all of a sudden here I am
back in the fucking grind again.
I thought I escaped shit.
Talking about Colorado,
I got to give up.
I got to give a shout out to customers.
[inaudible] son.
When I first went to Colorado,
I had problems.
You know,
I was 1920 I just wanted to live and I didn't know,
but I had a friend who was going to,
he was in the,
let's all go together.
He was in the [inaudible].
Where did you train for judo?
I just want to call and to Colorado Springs Air Force.
He was in the,
I didn't actually,
well,
I train the train.
I went up there to watch the World Cup.
Okay.
I got a chance to work out why I was up there.
So I technically trained at the Olympic training center,
but I didn't like train with the team.
I just was up there.
So he was inspirational.
He had gone to school there and got thrown out and then he was living in Aspen
and he talked me,
he's like,
go out there.
They shoveled snow and I didn't know.
So one day I go out and talk to my Stepdad and I see this like distant cousin of
mine.
He's like cousins through marriage and he's telling me,
I'm thought,
he was like,
what are you gonna do with your life?
And I'm thinking of going to Colorado.
He's like,
Colorado is the place to be.
I got a house in Aspen and shit.
What the fuck did you get money to live in Aspen?
Cuba's dude who plays congress in a band.
He's like,
yeah,
I've got a house and has been next to Nicholson Bitch.
And I'm like,
stop it.
I'm going to look your shit up dog.
Don't fuck know me.
I'll show up.
Right dog.
I get to Colorado.
I ask around,
I go,
listen,
I gotta get up to ask me to go to this borough.
This is pre cell phones.
By the way,
here's this hitchhiking up there.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
this is one you just hit.
So you can take the bus from basalt path.
Did you hitch or did you take it back in those days there was a hitching post
and Aspen and besought brought the hitching policy.
I'm more stories about you cause there was a hitching post and aspirin.
Didn't you get picked up?
I one of the eagles.
Fuck yeah.
Darn motherfucking Henley and a half.
And I got picked up on the bottom,
must snow mass by John Denver on the bottom going up for 4th of July.
And we just talked,
he picked me up in a brown jeep.
My mother,
when they had the eagles and on the front,
I remember the old school that James used to have the eagles.
He had an ego.
Colorado is the bomb.
Don Henley seems like mother picked me up in the truck and they kept saying,
dog,
I fucking know you.
And he can say,
no you don't.
And then he was recommending me for something or something like he was like,
I'll tell you where the restaurant is.
And he moved shit over and he had a checkbook and I said,
Don Henley construction company.
Well motherfucker [inaudible] his big song was done at that time.
It was uh,
it was the first single out that he put on the dirty laundry.
That's how long ago that was.
That was fucking dirty laundry motherfucker.
Holy Shit.
Did you have to suck his dick?
No,
he was very nice.
Very,
I had never hitchhiked.
I could never do that shit.
They
listen,
this is aspen,
Colorado guys circa 1983.
They didn't even have cable television then.
We ain't nothing but white people.
He will tell the leader up there at the time they had one channel channel too
and all they did was play Charles Bronson movies cause he lived up there.
They would play Mr Majestic and something else to the end.
I loved it and it was just so I was telling you about this dude tweety his name
was tweeting while I was growing up and he's like,
dog look me up when you go out there.
I get the basalt,
boom.
I got a ride up.
The fucking maroon bells.
When I'm in Maroon Bells,
I walk,
it's fucking far.
I get to his house,
he's got a gorgeous house.
There's a fucking Mercedes in the driveway.
I rang the bell is tweety here?
Who?
Tweedy?
Oh you're talking about a and hold on.
Robert comes out with a robe and he invites me in and he's like,
come on nose money.
Listen,
I don't ask no questions.
You know me.
I'm an AI.
And those days I didn't ask him a question.
I had gone to his wedding when he married into my distance type of Cuban family.
So he has this house.
So we're there and also that would go up there like once a weekend and party
with them,
my party.
But like a cook and we talk about human shit and one day he's like,
come here for a second,
look down there.
Look who sunbathing down there.
Sure enough bench.
It was Jack Nicholson with three little fucking blind hose.
I was a kid from New York.
Sound like Aspen and act.
This is maroon bells.
This is one of the prettiest spot in the world.
They say Maroon Bells,
Colorado.
It's just fucking Boise.
Jack Nicholson last talk killed it before CMC.
This is 80 fucking three had three Batman and shit.
Stop it.
Is this some pre,
this is pre Batman.
Is this pre that the fucking,
yeah,
but not Batman.
Who's the crazy movie in Colorado?
What movie?
What the fuck is it called?
All over the Cuckoo's nest?
No,
no.
The one that horror movie.
The Stephen King of all the shining.
The shining,
shining.
I think it was after the show.
This is after each visit.
Why he fell in love with Colorado mountains and they pay you up.
There you lay,
I can live here.
So fucking I kept visiting him.
He would say to me,
dog,
meet me up at Galena Street,
Galina streets.
The biggest treat NASPA.
I grew up there,
he had a store named Far East treasures.
They had one carpet in it.
I swear to God,
every time I go to have one fucking carpet in there.
Oh my God,
what fucking carpet of this.
So to make a long story short,
he would come and pick me up and bizarre.
He was more like distant cousins.
We became friends.
I introduced them to my friends and shit.
So one day,
one fucking,
well,
I'm living in Snowmass now.
This is like four months later and I hadn't seen tweet and like two months and
all of a sudden my bag of the call,
they're like dog dog,
put on cs,
whatever to it was dead.
Two channels,
don't ask me,
I think,
I don't want to insult your dog,
but there's been some problems and you've got to see,
I think this is the dude that says he's your cousin.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
That dude that lives in maroon bells.
You got to see this shit.
So that's when I pull on the fucking TV and they go back to what happened today
and Aspen,
Colorado,
a DEA and caught with a guy.
In the end they show this airplane and they show a DEA plane behind them and
they show bales of cocaine going get thrown out
and they show this guy and I'm like,
oh fucking tweeny.
So to tweedy was a DEA agent or PT will tweet.
He was a dealer.
Okay.
Sba chasten him on the plane.
He's on the fucking plane.
Wave in this shit.
Throwing up gang signals was out of the fucking plane.
I see this.
I kept,
my head's about to explode.
Oh my God,
my stepfather,
he's like,
you didn't fuck it.
And all that.
I used to big time,
I'm like,
come on.
And I'm like,
Bro,
he lives next to Nicholson.
He must be doing something.
So I go home.
I'd never seen tweedy again.
Thursday night I go to flap was with my boy,
talked about on stage.
So Matt side,
these two guys coming to me,
you want to smoke a bong?
Let's go.
We walked across the street,
started smoking it,
bond.
They're like,
oh,
you must know her uncle tweety I grew up with too greedy,
always,
whatever it says.
If we knew you,
I got dog tweenies out of jail thinking,
well he just guy.
He just 17 fucking years,
17 years for trafficking.
Wow.
Mom,
did they get all his money or they too,
he's working in a supermarket.
It's a tragic,
you know,
it's the American dream.
Dove.
Wow.
Someone needs to find that dude and get a fucking Martin Scorsese script written
and when you're fuck,
you know what I'm saying?
But that they shit,
they played that video.
It became,
in those days,
there was no web page.
It became a viral television thing.
Like the war on drugs continues to look at this video from Aspen.
So he was throwing it out of them and playing around on the fucking plane and
they were being chased me and chased.
Wow.
That's a complete different level of drug dealer.
That's,
you know,
there was a lot of those guys.
There's a lot of those guys that made it very,
very high up and they always maintain the celebrity connections.
You know,
they always maintain these weird weird network of movie star friends and I mean
that's always the case whenever like in,
in,
in cocaine cowboys.
Did they talk about that and cooking cowboys?
They would.
Was it?
No,
it was a different one.
It was another documentary where they're talking about,
uh,
how these,
drug dealers love to be around celebrities and you know,
kind of makes them feel like they're legit.
It could be around Jack Nicholson,
man,
if you're a Jack Nicholson,
maybe it was the black dudes from Atlanta,
that valley,
they would just painful for celebrities to come hang out with them.
Really,
they would just pull up,
gauge just how much the Joe Rogan accomplish this mother fuckers.
Really the whole 50,000.
We'll give him 75 get his ass.
He a Friday night.
Do you,
do you ever do a corporate gigs or someone,
some corporation asks you to show up and do stand up?
Really?
I do one a year and I bombing.
That's the problem.
They're all death John have on does a lot of,
it tends to like him.
He always get killer.
He's a killer for that stuff though.
His Act is perfect.
His Act is hilarious.
But squeaky clean.
You know John Half Ron is a,
he's the perfect guy for like any corporate thing.
Stefan came up with a new idea,
you know,
I don't know if we should,
I don't know.
I can't say it because it be giving up his idea,
but he's going to,
he's going to teach comedy to people to like,
uh,
to help their businesses.
It's going to help them.
Uh,
I don't want to say anymore.
Right.
So his idea
something,
one,
one of those weird things and I happened the other day,
we had a guy named Carlos on our,
one of our desk squad shows the other day.
I saw his name.
His name is Carlos Harena.
I'm saying his last name wrong.
Harissa Carlos.
I can't spell it.
H.
E.
R.
A.
I always was Herrera Herrera.
I can never say his last name.
Anyways.
Uh,
we,
the Salvia show you're talking about.
Yeah.
What we did is we had a show where we had all these people do Salvia,
Ari Shaffir did Salvy we have a lawn tomorrow,
so we'll talk about talking about.
Nice.
Uh,
and then we had a couple of other people that never did sell.
One person was Alison.
We had her on the podcast a while back.
Uh,
Alison Shula and out of nowhere,
I haven't talked to her months.
I just,
I just thought,
Hey,
I'm gonna call Alison up.
So she comes over and we have Carlos on.
And the reason why we had Carlos on his,
because he was one of the guys responsible making this thing called,
uh,
the mostly normal show presents the outing of a joke thief.
See what happened is this,
there's this guy that we had talked about and they,
Mitch,
Mitch [inaudible],
he's a really nice guy who died a few years back.
He said this,
he died.
And uh,
this guy has taken his act joke by joke and it wasn't even like,
he just took the joke out of it.
He actually watched a video of it and memorized how the guy did it.
Like,
like almost like an actor.
It's so creepy to watch.
So these guys,
uh,
they kind of,
hmm,
I I see where this is going.
I would rather not play this on the show.
Oh No,
we won't play that.
People can check it out.
But this is how crazy this is.
I mean,
uh,
the video is identical from the two like sure.
Like it's crazy.
But the weird thing is,
remember when Alison was on,
and we had talked about being a open mic comic and how a lot of these guys are
doing these tricks and one of the things that Allison was talking about is how
this guy wanted her to pay $100 in order to do five minutes in the belly ring
belly room.
And she was going to do that because she thought that's what you had to do to be
an open mic comic hundred dollars.
This guy was scamming her,
found out that during that episode of the Salvia video found out this is the
same guy,
that joke thief guy that was scamming her add money and other open comics out of
money.
She paid a hundred girls sucking my dick and giving me cope from Julie.
You think I'm fucking kidding you?
Fuck yeah,
you got to suck my Dick Nigga up in the belly room and make a call for you.
That's the,
that's the fucking gateway in to come in the Hollywood.
Everybody knows that.
How many girls did you have to do that?
All 20 of them.
I had this little blind open mic check dog that used to come up to the comedy
store with 20 and just take me up to the belly room was suck my dick then go do
his set.
She was tremendous.
Wow.
Finally freaked out when she got the Hollywood bowl and she was beautiful and
when she left she had dirty fucking nails with dirty and then a year later she
wrote me a letter to the calm,
you still,
you cock sucker.
You left me.
I kept shooting sperm balls in her fucking hair ball.
Every time she went down to the body I bought Bingo.
It ain't broken.
Throw.
Somebody fixes it.
This is the picture that guy that stole the comics and he look what he's reading
is reading the idiot's guide to comedy writing.
Yeah.
Listen man,
that dude's living in his own hell.
There's no need to outdoor guy.
He's,
it's obviously all out there,
but check it out.
I don't really
shocking video Joe you and actually like,
I didn't really want to watch it
but I don't want to watch it because Mitch was a friend of mine.
He was a nice guy.
Poor fuck.
What this guy is is just some guy who thinks he can slither into this world.
You know,
it's like we were talking about earlier this comics and then this people who
think they could figure out a way to be a comic,
you know,
let me look.
We all want to be's were all want to in the beginning,
but eventually you either embrace the art form or you don't.
Everybody in the beginning is a fraud.
Everyone is in the beginning is pretending you're make believing you're a
comedian and some people think that this is the way to do it.
This guy's an idiot.
He's probably been,
you hear about the hundred dollars thing.
He's probably been running his whole life like that.
Just one scan.
I wouldn't have asked for $100 a blow job is legit.
That's known.
You know what I'm saying?
And that's right.
A blow job in the hundred dollars is bad,
right?
When you shoot it,
I am become death.
If you strongly believe by sucking a Dick,
you're going to get onstage.
Shame on you.
But sometimes if they buy it,
I got the fucking Russian you,
they did get onstage.
What are you saying?
If you believe that's how you got him on stage,
you suck.
They suck your Dick.
You did put them on stage.
So why wouldn't they believe it?
I'm,
that's reality.
Never forget that that blonde girl at first time I told it dog,
I was like,
she came up on a Friday night.
She's like,
Joey,
I know you know people.
You get me.
And I looked at straight to the face as a joke and I go,
go,
you're gonna have to say no.
I said to,
I didn't even say Suck Dick to be.
I said,
I get you on stage,
we have to work.
And she goes,
what do you mean like a little put you to work at this?
You got to do something.
You gotta do something
rather way.
They know.
They know there's a fucking cost at the gate.
They even look at you like,
what?
Those puppets,
and she even looked at me and goes,
I'm not really good at you have to teach me.
Oh,
sell for it.
Beautiful for themselves.
They know that.
Told that that's what,
that's comedy.
Would it make it even better when a girl says that you can have to ta was this
that Oh God damn.
Just to learn.
Should we gave a seven twenties for a hundred went back to her house and I told
him at the house we had a great time of,
but she had a period,
but I went to either ask you a tissue paper.
Oh
and I just suck.
You Suck my Dick.
I can't handle that.
Buffalo,
it was like five in the morning.
Oh,
that point.
I'll get all fucked up.
I wouldn't need to get a little pussy if you had a period,
but I will.
I'll look.
Yes.
I'll just write the payment cycle.
Whack,
lump on your neck,
us up.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh,
I got to look a little muffly just to,
I get the party started and she had like a little crumble,
like it was just not even like what it was like a,
it was like a little crumble dingleberry like not even,
it wasn't a dingleberry.
It's like somebody shut a spit ball and then it has
fuck this and it was just dangling there that it just killed me dog.
I was like,
oh,
I can't even use a rest my dick the whole night and I haven't known how to work
with Paul Rodriguez and I can say mark Babbitt picked me up like at eight in the
morning.
I know,
ma'am.
Did you get a good night's sleep?
Oh yeah,
sure.
Fuck out of here.
I'm going to get my dick sucked him.
My boss Lik that's commonly stole one old one the old days,
Joe Rogan.
God,
a bunch of Shit happens since we stopped doing the podcast in the last two
weeks.
One of them is the Arnold Schwartzenegger thing.
God Damn is this one of the craziest fucking stories ever.
Arnold Schwarzenegger apparently was not just fucking this lady.
This housekeeper tried to fuck her mom.
What?
Yeah,
he groped her mom and he groped her sister.
They all worked for him and those pitches will I get out of here and then he
great grow up that one lady and she was like,
oh,
come on and do some of that Conan Dick.
That's crazy.
It's hotter cause I had to be all there.
They're all got,
come on.
Little don't think it matters.
I think he's one of those dudes.
And you know,
Ryan Parson said it pat.
So I was hanging out doing a movie with Ryan,
who's a,
the,
one of the,
uh,
one of the best coaches in MMA and he cheese mayhem,
Miller's coach.
And we were,
he's a smart dude.
He breaks things down and we were talking about Arnold and he goes,
you know,
one man,
he goes,
I'm not surprised at all.
He goes,
he was a professional bodybuilder and I was like,
you're right.
Like don't a lot of those guys do a lot of gay shit because they need money and
apparently gay dudes will pay bodybuilders.
Ridiculous heels.
Like,
Oh yeah,
he was,
especially back in the 70s he goes,
they were all suck and rich guys cost
money.
Yeah.
He said it used to dress up my Batman suit and go to fucking rich white bodies
and shit with a little mask on it.
I don't think he would even have a copy,
which is of him,
you know,
he's,
he,
he was so weird.
You know,
I can remember when he did pumping iron and he started,
man,
I'm always gumming.
Every time I have a palm bay bamboo is like calming.
So I'm always palmed them always coming.
I'm coming all the time.
Like just the fact that he would think that it's cool to just like talk about
just shooting loads all the time in 1978 or whatever the fuck it was.
He's doing a documentary about bodybuilding and here's this dude with a little
fucking banana hammock on talking about coming.
I'm coming off the dime.
He's,
he's a weird man.
He's a,
he's a freak.
He's a freak and then Jane Seymour comes out and says that he's apparently got a
bunch of little love children.
I guarantee he's going to buy eight of them.
He's just a savage.
He's just shooting those barbarian loads and the women that the ball from the
seventh I shouldn't make them Germans go cray.
That's what killing him to go bananas.
That people that the ball,
what's not a shift in the 70s I used to just swell your shit up.
See now they got refined steroids.
I don't make you a fucking savage or Arnold was legendary for doing every day.
Every day.
Always talk about whatever everybody,
anyone who was doing Arnold was taking shit to the next level.
Ball walking.
He even shot fucking Lance Armstrong and shit.
That motherfucker,
you're seeing,
you had lance Armstrong suck.
It lands.
You're doing an old wrong.
You don't even nuts and berries and the designer.
I don't think I've ever heard of the nice thing about Lance Armstrong and when I
seen that thing on 60 minutes,
all I kept thinking about was it couldn't happen to a fucking nice a guy.
Well,
I'll tell you one in Austin,
when we go to Austin,
we never hear nothing but shitty things about him.
Yeah,
I couldn't.
I've heard this weird man.
He did something to somebody I know in La,
something shitty at a restaurant.
Something happened.
You talked to the Lord,
the wrong people.
You can get shitty stories about the nicest people.
No,
I bet up somewhere out there,
Henry Winkler,
there's some asshole shitty Henry Winkler story.
It's just if you deal with sheer numbers,
but you know,
if you do like most people you talk to and they say,
oh,
I met Randy coture.
I such a nice guy,
isn't he?
Like most people will tell you that,
but he a few.
Every now and then you get some one dude that was probably annoying as fuck and
came up to Randy and tried to get him in a headlock by picture when you're at
the restaurant,
interrupted him.
I was eating dinner or something and whatever the fuck it was.
And so then you'll get a shitty Randy coture story.
But I never heard a good Lance Armstrong story every time you were in Austin.
I have a hard,
but we were all hearing it from waiters and waitresses and yeah,
and people that know people that ran into him.
It was never good.
You know,
to be that dude to be a one dude who pretends that he's the one who wasn't doing
shit when everyone else is doing.
I love that shit.
I love when they get nailed.
Don't have some fucking dignity.
Be a fucking man.
Nah,
he don't know.
He wants to stand behind the paperwork.
Yes and no because there's a big business behind all this k and there's a lot of
people that knew he was doing things is one of the things in the 60 minutes
documentary about it,
the 60 minutes coverage of it.
They say that he tested positive for EPO at one point in time and then after he
tested positive,
he donated money to this,
this blood scanning foundation that bus people for for fucking testing positive
for shit.
He don't even like 25 grand and then he donated another hundred grand in the
future.
Like what?
But you mean that's a payoff man.
That's like a direction shit.
This guy was really doing EPO and all the other dudes,
they're busting them left and right.
They all have to,
they all have to come clean and they have to tell only the truth.
Cause if they get caught with anything then their immunity goes out the window.
So they give him a limited amount of immunity.
We tell them we want to know every fucking thing that happened.
And if you lie about one thing,
you're going to jail,
your immunities gone.
You're going to jail for everything you've already admitted to.
So that 25 fucking years you believe that shouldn't go steroids.
I'm sorry because I made a joke and I got plenty for the five emails from
people.
Hey fat ass.
He wasn't doing steroids,
he was doing tests or whatever.
You know what bitch,
he was still cheap.
That's like me telling you I wasn't doing heroin.
I was doing though.
It's the same fucking different.
I think they all do it though.
I think in that sport.
I think in that sport they have to,
I don't think,
you know,
um,
they test you and you're not supposed to do it,
right?
Yeah.
And then they'd blood dope as well instead of taking just the EPO,
they blood dope dope.
And there,
that's,
that's a fact.
I mean,
you know,
Joe,
they've been doing that.
He can't catch people.
We have it right in the wrong sometimes in life is sometimes for fucking riding
a bike.
You gotta do this shit.
This guy was said somewhere,
you know,
I don't think they should arrest Barry bonds now after he retired two years ago.
Now I'm breaking his balls.
It's over.
And when did they get Barry bonds on?
They got him on some real minor shit.
Like lying.
Right.
You're talking about?
Probably about they'll help you with something that gets you,
they'll find,
so yeah,
they get you on perjury,
right?
So even if you lie,
who was going to tell me that you would go?
Come,
can I talk to any other room?
Listen,
I got 19 fucking sponsorships for right.
One of them is a Catholic church.
You want it all Christian Church and the other one's gate array.
You want to ask me if I do steroids on a fucking camera?
What do you want me to tell you?
What are you want me to tell you?
I've got millions of fucking stake here.
What do you want me to tell you?
It's not perjury.
We did it.
You don't want me in the hall of fame?
Go Fuck Yourself.
I got a pension and I got money coming,
but you're going to waste taxpayers' money.
Barry Bonds to court.
Who did he hurt?
It is interesting though,
because you got to think that if these guys are doing shit that's dangerous for
their body and you know it is kind of dangerous,
especially the guys that go deep.
You go the Arnold Schwarzenegger levels,
you know,
you know you go to like pro wrestling levels,
re those giant fucking dudes.
That's dangerous as fuck.
Like you're,
you're,
you're really overclocking.
It's true.
60 [inaudible] he's still here.
Yeah,
true.
For him being he also guys open heart surgery,
right?
I,
but there's 10 guys that the gun,
it's true.
Every time you listen to it.
Anytime you'd do a bump of cocaine,
a mushroom,
a fucking five hour energy,
a steroid,
you always,
you always gone in that area.
You're always 55th coaching to buy anything.
You're pushing them body.
So yeah,
maybe 50% 50% of that would do it.
How many times?
I did coke for 30 years.
The basketball player pushes Boston the line and had a heart attack.
We're all different.
You say it the best.
Some guy,
the Georges has a certain number.
Yup.
The head
just has a certain number.
It could be five shots to the head to get brain or it could be a hundred and
fucking,
it depends on if you're Samoan.
Well it depends on anything.
We don't know that number,
but once you get to the steroids or whatever,
any of that shit.
Yeah,
it's true.
it's all,
look,
I'm a personal freedom person,
but I also think that man,
if a kid wants to be a cyclist,
he shouldn't have to take some shit that might give them a stroke.
And the only way to win,
if you're going to have a bunch of dudes were an EPO,
an EPO can give you strokes.
I don't know how many people have died from it,
but I assume it's gotta be a few and it is dangerous.
I know people that have told me,
they know people who took it.
You know the guys that are professional cyclist and they detailed how difficult
and dangerous it was and how they would have to wake up in the middle of the
night and do cardio.
They would have to get up and go ride their bike because their heart would be
fucking pounding because their,
their blood is too thick because they have all this shit in their body that
makes them make an,
an abnormal amount of red blood cells.
So on the plus side you carry all this oxygen.
But on the downside,
man,
if you don't work out all the time and you could die,
like you could have a fucking stroke man,
these dudes would,
he was a cyclist and he was staying on a,
on a bus and he said you would hear him at two,
three in the morning and you would know who was on EPO cause those are the guys
who would get up and they would,
and you would hear their bike,
you'd hear them disconnect their bike and go Rodan till three in the morning,
man,
they had to do it.
If you don't do it,
you're gonna die.
So in on one hand,
I believe in personal freedom.
Then another hand I go,
well you know you got to let people know what the fuck you're doing.
You can't make it so that the only the guys at the top are taking the shit in
line about taking it.
That does become a problem if you say,
hey look,
we all take it.
Everybody takes it.
It's a part of the world of cyclists and it's been there forever.
Then expose light on it and then you've got to figure out what,
if anything you can do about it.
But it is a dangerous thing.
You know,
you're,
you're telling kids that want to be athletes that they have to do this shit.
You know,
there's no way around it and be professional sport today there's gotta be
something involved or supreme genetics.
You can have a guy like Jon Jones,
magnificent genetics and he doesn't need anything.
Or you know,
there's other guys that are built like that too.
or similar,
you know,
there's a lot of guys,
you don't need anything.
They just have awesome genetic,
I don't care what you do as long as you're a professional athlete.
I know the stresses of being a professional athlete,
especially football bat one should there,
the pressure is amazing.
Every year that rook and people,
even in the UFC now watch ramp pays the other night.
But then you got my man Rick story than other young kid to the company in the
UFC that 20 and a half away,
whatever.
You know,
people come on every once in a while,
but also kids had come in that pop that piss hot,
they get rid of them right away about pissing holiday anything.
What I'm saying is that it's very tough to not want to stay at your sharpest,
but if you do steroids against what you did,
steroids,
there's no way are we tracking them.
So do me a favor.
Figure out a way that when you make that first fucking statement,
you can edit it instead of dragging off the fucking 10 years.
What are you going to say?
You got to say nothing.
Don't hit me with a story that you guys shot him into yarn because I'm too for
that one.
Told me anything but don't tell me that and that's what I'm sick of right now at
this point in my life.
Tell me something.
Don't hide.
Don't get the prep.
You know what?
You got busted.
Get the fucking cameras and let's go.
That's cool.
Y'All silver had some nonhuman pis.
Oh please.
I'm what the fuck the showing up.
We're pissed on Brazil.
Kevin Random.
It was the first guy to do that.
Kevin ran one,
had a rubber Dick.
He used a rubber deck.
Any really non human urine.
Ben,
have you heard anything from him lately?
He's kind of retired,
fought recently.
Real recently in the last,
I love people who think they're going to be the urine test.
I just want to be great to those fucking clowns.
Kevin Randleman was awesome.
I love those fucking clowns because I was with them.
I always thought I was a little bit beat the system.
I used to drink vinegar,
that would be it.
So I would snort coke Friday and Saturday night.
Listen to me,
listen to me,
listen to what addiction does or any level.
God,
I used to do an eight ball on Friday ball on Saturday and then they would have
to test me on Monday for federal probation or Wednesday or Friday.
I could make the Piss test Wednesday,
but there's no way I can make this rock candy coming out his deck.
I would fucking vinegar flavored rock candy,
go and get white distilled vinegar with a bottle of Gatorade and I'd be
cranberries,
but be,
I drink the whole thing of vinegar,
the whole thing again.
The rape kiss all day come.
Where did you learn this?
This is the stories on this.
This is all the analogies you learned from people in your read.
That time there was no Internet Joe,
right?
So then I failed actor,
then I came up with another idea.
I must do it.
And so how many days had it been?
You did.
You did coke Friday and said if you do coke on a Friday and you have a test on a
Monday,
you're going down.
But if you wait till Wednesday,
you're good.
Two hours,
70 to 72 hours and you can't flush it out at some can't flush that.
Some magnetic fucking correlation.
Weed is 30 days.
But if you keep your normal level,
like if you just hit two hits off a joint and go to a gym,
I did a dog,
they won't catch it real.
It can't be nothing in your system.
You can't show up now.
And then a month.
No,
no,
no.
I can go.
If at that time all I needed,
we was to go to the gym.
How do you think Nick Diaz is doing it?
He dog.
He wrestles every,
you do Jiu Jitsu every day.
Just sweat Sadie and not do 50 bucks enough fat to a story.
CanNot do 50 bond hits,
but you could do to bond gets and keep it under the level.
Nick did a lot of bagels.
I do whatever,
but holds on about Nick Diaz.
Forget about Nancy poppy seeds.
So that's for heroin.
So that's a different thing.
But take it to the point where those days,
what's the funny thing was I figured I'm smarter than these motherfuckers.
Forget about drinking.
I'm going to take my own circumcised Dick and I'm gonna pull the skin back and
I'm going to put byproducts in there.
Sit down,
sit out bitch.
Cause you don't,
what about Joey Diaz Circa 1987 I would have to go in my mind.
I thought it out and I said to myself,
what kills piss on contact.
Got Clorox.
But I can't sneak that into money.
So I said,
what's the next best thing to kill pissed?
So I figured out pool cleaners,
right?
So I went to my buddy's house who had a pool,
you know those big things that he'd say,
oh no,
Maureen and I grind it that I like rather that motherfucker.
I grinded that motherfucker like a fucking grab a blow to a powder and I took my
little skin on my helmet and I pulled my dick back before I went to probation
and I did my dick in.
It didn't hurt and I just pull it all the,
the whole fucking thing on my dick.
And I pulled the skin over and I like a rubber band that
this is what addiction makes you do,
Brian.
I walk into probation,
ready a Piss,
Mr. I take that Dick out and I popped that skin back and all of that volcano bus
goes in there and that thing starts breathing on his own booboo,
blah,
blah.
I put the cap on it.
The thing is on his desk and you could see it in my fucking,
we've,
you could see it like shaking.
I'm like,
oh,
great to see you.
Do you know what bitch,
I still came back positive.
Now here's the clinker,
the clinker.
This is when you know you're fucking crazy.
Then the last thing I figured was Draino I'll take drain,
but this was the,
you were drinking.
No.
Can't they detect who?
Listen to me now listen to me.
The chlorine the next day didn't hurt.
I went right to the halfway house on wash my dick off,
but the next day I went to Piss and my dick was like one of those.
This was coming out of everywhere.
But yeah,
I had like,
it would just broke.
It was like a fucking thing.
I came back for that one little holes.
It burnt right to my helmet.
Oh my God.
At this point,
fucking Britain on the blow Jack.
Oh my.
So I came back positive.
They made me go to rehab that time or a check in,
but one that you give them a grant and you go three to six and you signed papers
and Elizabeth Therapy,
here's 20 bucks.
I'll be back on that.
And nobody,
even the folks,
they just want that grand up front and that's it.
You don't need,
that's what we have is you don't,
at that time,
this was boulder.
This is 1800 bucks.
I got a grant from the state.
It cost me 400 but it kept me out of jail for it.
So you don't have to actually be there.
Now you just go from three to six at night.
You tell him you got a day job.
It was tremendous.
So this last time they get me again for blow.
I know they're going to fucking sick me.
So this time I said,
fuck it.
I'm going to plan the one I heard,
I heard Draino so I took drain on.
I pulled it off my dick go home and I went down.
Eric Gad fucking pissed with the drain.
Okay.
And this time dog,
that thing was turning red right in front of me.
You could see the thing going up and down is the pis and about four days late,
I get a call.
Mr. Diaz,
can you come down to probation?
I had to throw going to handcuff me a probation.
I get there and as a car does it,
probation loss and the gang got in the check.
There was a chick that really liked me.
She goes,
I don't know what you did,
but you fucking broke the machine this time.
I really literally broke the testing thing they had.
They couldn't even,
they didn't know what was in my system.
[inaudible]
I drop her a quick,
where was the,
you put the drain on your Dick.
Oh my God.
Was calling them possible.
Doesn't it eat right through your Dick?
I mean that's during the day before,
right.
Just had chlorine the day before at this planning.
Give a fuck.
I was living like a bitch.
Yo
dismisses the next day after you had to Corrine.
This was about a month later.
I had sores on there.
It looked like a fucking bay root cause you said the day before I got
[inaudible] but it was funny that they nailed me.
They were like,
Joey,
we know you have coke but we can't prove it in court.
How do they know he had coke done?
Because whatever.
I had in my broke the fucking drink.
You sure it was real drain cause I know I was running from the fucking flea
market.
Yeah,
it was real fucking drain.
I think draino like it could sound like a Chi Empire.
My fucking helmet,
his girlfriend and clogged his girlfriend split or something dog.
My Dick was rare for a fucking month.
Let's not get away with this shit.
It was rather,
you know when you pee and it goes on get help and it would stick with me and he
brought it on a Thursday.
That's how sick.
That's how bad the stick of this was.
Your
life is when your dick a sore.
There's something wrong with your dad.
He realize,
what have I done?
The fuck is wrong with me.
Crazy off till I got blisters on my feet.
Dog Find that like three times in my life.
All the time.
Fucking the other day I scraped my nail against my dick and then fucking start
bleeding.
It's discussed.
What's the latest with Joe Eddie Bravo fighting?
Uh,
it's off completely off.
The dude wants money.
He wants a $50,000.
We agreed to the fight,
but then he said he wants $50,000 and then 25,000 if he wins.
So apparently the shake talked moon,
whoever was putting together one of the shakes over there,
not put dollar.
He was like,
you can't do that,
dude.
You're asking for too much money.
But who knows?
They might.
They might come to some sort of an agreement.
I think Horley is 45 years old,
man.
You know,
it's tough to get that due to fight.
If he's going to fight,
he wants some cash.
Isn't Eddie just then fight that best grade?
It's not that would fight him because he doesn't really want to fight anybody.
He just was going to fight this dude because this dude's always saying that him
beating him was a fluke and then it was,
it would never happen again.
Lightning doesn't strike twice and he's like,
oh,
okay.
Really?
Well let's do it again.
I'll tell you the reality is Eddie's better.
I don't know if boilers better than he was back then,
whether it's an all time great and was beating Eddie before he tapped him.
Right.
But I don't know,
you know,
a boiler consistently improves.
I don't know if he still has the passion for it,
but I know Eddie is a lot better than it was back then.
It doesn't mean he would win quite grace.
He's a bad motherfucker dude.
I mean he won a ton of tournaments.
He won Abu Dhabi several times.
He's one of the most active members of the Gracie family.
Like he was the guy that was holding it down for the Gracie family in Jujitsu
tournament.
You know,
back when Hixon wasn't competing anymore and Hickson was always the greatest.
Everybody always says that.
But hoist was doing the UFC for a little bit.
But as far as like straight Jujitsu,
fighting the best in the world,
oil or Gracie was holding it down for years,
man.
And he was the man.
He was beating everybody.
So you know,
it was a big upset when Eddie tapped him and you know,
it was embarrassing,
I'm sure.
And he doesn't like it and I'm sure he doesn't want to have a repeat of that for
nothing,
you know?
And when he wants to get paid and if he beats him,
he wants to,
you know,
and once I get motivated to work out to beat him and for Eddie,
Eddie says,
look,
I'll fight that guy.
That's the only guy I want to fight.
I want to prove to everybody that wasn't a fluke.
I think Yeti's better man.
He's way better than he was back then.
I don't,
I'm not saying he's better than a boiler still.
Like I said,
I'll respect the heuler.
He's an all time great,
but I know that Eddie's a lot better than he was when he beat him last time.
People go in there like just like,
I don't always,
students love him,
but people go there for a couple of days.
We'll come back with that say bro.
And he's bare to the bone.
Yeah,
you take the,
you know his guard ain't shit.
He's going to wrap you up and fuck you up dude.
Even if you're a lot bigger than he tell you the whole story about what he went
over there and I would Dobbin weight train with the guy,
but the guys trainer was a hen's old guy.
Yeah,
the whole story.
Very interesting.
Yeah it is.
I slowed down that.
It's a bad motherfucker.
Eddie's a Jujitsu genius.
I've always said this,
you know,
he's just a crazy guy and people look at him and he does all this music and all
these different things so they get it twisted.
But when it comes to straight Jujitsu,
Nicole Nicole's,
they can't man,
he's a great fucking instructor.
Let's,
the way he breaks down techniques,
he's excellent at it,
man.
I've been to a lot of UFC is with you and I've never had a bad time.
But one of the funniest things beside this trip and at the UFC was the way and
would Eddie and what's the kid that I love him with the fucked up I for a while.
He's fighting against now big kid,
one 84 Yak Akiyama and he beat them.
Akiyama beat him the first Akiyama his first fight.
I always forget his name,
cubs,
Alan Belcher,
Alan Belcher.
So we're hanging out.
I haven't,
I forbid I don't go to the front and the way in the back of my,
my business,
I won't say nothing cause somebody might beat me up.
They're talking,
they're talking like the way we are.
Awesome.
He goes,
Bro.
Bro,
did you just see my new technique and Allen Belt?
Just like,
no,
what is it?
He's like,
oh,
it's called this.
And so like I dunno and the next thing you know they're on the ground.
Fuck you.
They in the ring.
Yeah,
bitch dumb in the ring.
And they got their shoes off and I was sitting there and I went,
oh my God.
And he's just taken Alan Belcher and just,
you know,
hooks and legs.
I don't know what they're called,
but I know Alan Belcher was blown away in
golf.
You know,
Jujitsu with something that,
you know,
Eddie,
Eddie Bravo would be like one of the most respected coaches in the country.
He was a huge,
you know,
and I don't think he's a just a golfer,
I don't think his coach.
But you know what I'm saying?
I mean,
if it was like something that was,
golf's a terrible example because it's sort of a game instead of a sport where
it's,
Jujitsu is clearly a sport.
He just,
uh,
you know,
he's,
he's always wanted to be a musician.
That's the real problem.
If he just wanted to only be a Jujitsu fighter and,
and,
and keep competing,
you know,
there's always been dudes that will beat him.
You know,
Havi Vasquez beat him a few times and this guy,
I mean,
Eddie's not the best in the world because he's not the best athlete,
but he's a Jujitsu genius man.
He sees shit.
He knows how to break shit down and everybody thinks that he like takes credit
for all this other shit,
but he really doesn't,
you know,
when you listen to him talk and teach and actually get to know the guy,
he gives credit for every
single person and learned every move from,
you know,
he,
there's certain,
you know,
there's a move called the do Dodd.
This is the John Joc sweep.
Like he doesn't rename shit.
That's other people's stuff.
If you learned it from somebody else,
man,
he always,
he literally call it,
you know,
this is a,
this is what Marcello uses,
this is the Marcello,
you know,
get to back position.
You know,
he gives up credit.
I left and right.
He's just a weird dude,
you know,
that's the problem.
You know,
he's,
he's a fucking,
he's basically,
you know,
he's an entertainer,
you know.
I mean,
he's a,
he music is his thing,
but it could have just as well been in.
He'd been,
it could have been an actor.
He easily could have been a comic.
You know,
we,
I tried to talk him into it,
he tried it for a while,
but he was doing too many different things.
He was trying to teach Jujitsu and try to do music and try and do comedy and it
was just too hard for him.
He,
he,
he came up with some good material and he was trying for a little bit,
but he's an entertainer,
you know,
it was just,
Jujitsu became something for him to focus his energy on and he got,
he's got a special knack for it.
And he's just a dude that if he focuses on shit,
he can get real good at shit.
He just doesn't get taken seriously because he's an entertainer.
You know,
we thought of,
you get thought of.
We all get thought of when you're an entertainer,
you get thought of as being a silly person.
You're not a,
you're not a person to be taken seriously.
You're a frivolous person,
you know,
because you're doing this and you know,
you're like,
look at me.
And when the game rude,
it could me
saw Doug Stan hope over the weekend.
That was Doug.
Really good man.
He,
and he did a really good show.
Different from his Oslo.
Yeah.
Well,
I didn't see that.
I saw most of it,
but what I saw was on new to me,
but a really cool seeing him,
man.
He,
uh,
yeah,
he,
he packed the comedy store by the way,
that main room two shows is packed night standing people Friday,
no one at night,
Thursday and Friday.
I told her that mother Fucker,
he's a bad dude.
It was 800.
All of this is 900 seats.
That's a weekend in some way.
What you just did it the two,
not even for 50 in the main route.
400.
And then,
you know what,
what's so awesome is that after the show I was sitting outside with my
girlfriend and we're just hanging out watching sunset.
About five people came up.
I was like,
hey man,
what's up?
All his fans knew I listened to your podcasts and stuff,
but it gave me so much Brownie points and like,
I was like,
wow,
you're famous.
Wow.
Did you get some extra pussy because of that?
Yes.
Look at him.
He's so happy.
That's all right.
So how was the Stan Hope set?
Good.
Really good man.
It was,
uh,
it was his best shit.
Um,
it was all new to me.
It was a lot of just regular Stan hope style material.
It was pretty good.
He uh,
he had a really funny joke a bit about,
uh,
baby pictures.
I don't have you ever heard him about my baby pictures were showing him baby
pictures.
So don't do as material who've you crazy.
No I'm not.
I'm not saying what it is.
Give up the premise.
It's about the big picture.
Did you um,
did you have to stand or did you sit down?
I stood just,
I mean I could've have stayed.
I didn't have a ticket so I just stood in the back.
That's the I learned from watching his last show.
No more.
No more standing on you and I both learned.
So I changed our whole show and we talked about it and Joey talked about to you
standing and watching a show is a fucking bitch.
That fun.
It ain't
fun for people.
So sit down bitches cause we got some shows coming up.
Yeah.
Joey and I are going to be in Pittsburgh at the Carnegie Music Hall and that is
Saturday,
January 25th it is already or not January,
June,
excuse me.
Saturday,
June 25th and it's already more than half sold out.
And then Joey can't go to Canada unfortunately.
But uh,
the vogue theater,
I'm going to be there with young Tom Segura and that motherfucker better not be
sick.
That's June 9th in Vancouver and that I believe is sold out.
I think there's the only thing that's available.
It's like a couple of seats.
And then on July 1st the full death squad will be at Mandalay Bay theater.
It'll be Joey Diaz.
Ari should fear me and Doug Benson is going to be in the neighborhood too.
So Doug Benson to probably do a guest set as well.
And if we get Brian fucked up enough,
maybe we'll throw him to the dogs too.
It's a big crazy theater and uh,
yeah,
that's a UFC weekend.
It's Dominick Cruz versus Uriah Faber bitches on Saturday jet July 2nd dop and
Faby.
God dammit calls.
I have to do it.
I don't,
don't come out him.
There's a bunch of good fighters,
a lot of good fights at July.
Second Card is the shit.
I'm sorry that we were away for so long,
but God damn,
it feels good to be back talking to you guys.
I hope you enjoyed the show.
I knew a plug.
Yeah,
sure.
How about Winston's is San Diego Sunday.
Saturday jewel fought the seven o'clock.
I've been there before.
It's a great little place.
Come on out and say hello.
We'll have some fucking banana bread.
Winston's and San Diego.
June 4th Saturday.
Yup.
Sat.
That's next weekend.
Next weekend.
Who you there with?
My myself.
Bunch of fucking San Diego guys.
Just rocking a lot of guys down there in San Diego.
La,
San Diego comicon.
There's a little community going on down there.
Fuck you.
Ocean beach or it's always a great time.
Itselves up.
So get down there.
The only pack like two incidents.
The place you played that big dome?
No,
he played.
I did.
Um,
fifth and main and always prop.
Juvenate oh,
June 8th is though.
That's your Wednesday show.
No,
I'm not taking my fucking CD in Vancouver.
I cut.
I couldn't get it cleared in time.
I'm going to have to hold it off for a few months.
Good.
Let's do Houston bit.
All the shots.
Ten nine we just take over fucking Improv or theater.
You had a choice.
What is it?
October 10 10 October 8th you'll definitely be ready.
Everybody's ready.
October 8th is the UFC heavy off?
So maybe we'd do it October like seventh sixth and seventh 87 till the two shows
in Houston.
Houston to be perfect.
We ain't been there forever.
Or you could just do the bud light extravaganza in New Orleans and make the
motherfucker drive from,
you've never done it New Orleans before.
Never done a fucking special.
That's a,
I think that's so September,
September 16th and that's already too quick.
But I don't know.
Maybe that gave up that information too early.
I don't know if that's public knowledge.
Public.
Is it public?
I've Jones and my man got a commercial lot.
That's why when he went to the doctor,
they said,
Jon Jones,
you kidding me?
You'll fight motherfucker.
You go into the warm leads,
motherfucker.
Joe is going to fight but think about it.
But by the way through the commercial with Dana as Dana was walking away,
twenties are falling out of his pocket.
So you know how that goes.
It's going to be a rampage versus John Jones.
That'll be,
where would you put that with the shit?
I put that New Orleans New Orleans ain't bad either.
Same mother fucking difference cause there's only two from Memphis to from
Houston.
They could come from all over.
You know what I'm saying?
Pick up by the check yourself before you wreck yourself.
What hell follow Joey on Twitter,
mad flavor m a d a v level or follow him on Twitter and thank you to all our new
friends on Sirius satellite radio.
We are,
we are honored to be on the virus with opening Anthony.
It's cool as fuck to hear us on there and thanks everybody for tuning in.
Oh yeah.
And thanks to the flashlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link and a and during the code named Rogan and you get 15% off the
number one sex toy from own pitchers and joy shoot loans.
And we have Ari Shaffir on tomorrow.
Ari Shaffir tomorrow and we're going to play Ari on Salvia where apparently he
tried to kill Brian and a,
Ari's going to talk about his a mushroom initiative.
He's trying to have a day where everyone in the country does mushrooms.
He's going to promote the shit out of that red bed.
Did it already.
And then we got Wednesday.
Yeah.
When red bands already done,
he's done for like I said,
six month period at least.
And then Wednesday we got Duncan Trussell so we've got a full three day death
squad week Dunkin Ren Joey,
just to make it up.
Thank you very much for having me.
Thank you for how you,
you always got some guy.
I've known you for 20 fucking years.
You always got new stories that haven't been all I've got on the GRE experience
cause this is all we gotta.
We gotta make some Jie experienced shirts.
Oh well I got the,
I got you.
I'm going to wait.
I shouldn't wear your shirt today.
I work tomorrow.
I can't worry a gyro.
And that's kind of a critique.
Where'd your own shirt?
It's so we up and talked about the hire desk,
primary.com they sold out literally within an hour,
and we got new ones coming in and we've got a bunch of new designs up their cock
suckers.
And,
uh,
we love you.
That's it.
Thank you very much.
Glad we ain't going nowhere.